J'ai jamais très bien compris les gens, le, le monde qui m'entoure. Bon, c'est l'occasion d'essayer. Je suis Guillaume Hachez, vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
Salut tout le monde, j'espère que vous allez bien. Après des semaines et des mois même de pure politique,
on se retrouve cette semaine avec un sujet qui est vraiment du Septante Minutes Avec pur jus puisqu'on va parler de neurodiversité avec mon invitée.
On avait déjà parlé de choses comme l'autisme, les troubles du comportement alimentaire ou la schizophrénie. Et aujourd'hui, on va s'intéresser à un trouble qui est nettement moins connu, je pense : le trouble de la personnalité borderline.
Il y a une traduction en français, mais je pense que personne ne l'utilise. Trouble de la personnalité limite, j'ai jamais entendu ça.
C'était super intéressant. Vous allez voir que comme souvent, le début est, voilà, assez scolaire. On revient sur les définitions, sur les symptômes du trouble.
Et puis on se dirige petit à petit vers des questions de plus en plus méta sur les enjeux de la neurodiversité. Et à ce propos, on utilise souvent, à travers cet entretien, l'abréviation de TDAH.
Pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas, c'est le trouble du déficit de l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité. On parle aussi d'autisme et pour ça, je vous renvoie aux supers épisodes qu'on avait faits avec Julie Dachez ou avec Marco Di Duca.
Dernière chose, on parle pas mal de médicaments, de diagnostics, de symptômes, de neurologie, toutes ces choses qui ont donné forme au périple que Fio a mené depuis son diagnostic.
Mais voilà, je vous rappelle tout de même que ni elle ni moi ne sommes médecins, que ce podcast ne fait pas office de conseil médical et que si vous estimez que vous en avez besoin, il faut surtout pas hésiter à consulter un médecin.
Enfin, si tant est qu'il ou elle soit formé sur ces enjeux, vous allez voir, on parle de tout ça. Bonne écoute. J'ai aujourd'hui le plaisir d'être avec Fiona Jestin. Salut Fio.
Salut.
On va parler aujourd'hui avec toi du trouble de la personnalité borderline. Est-ce que tu peux nous raconter un petit peu comment c'est arrivé dans ta vie ?
Yes. Déjà merci beaucoup de me recevoir. Ça me fait très plaisir d'être là, donc merci pour ça. Donc du coup, actuellement j'ai vingt-neuf ans et—
On a le même âge.
Oui. Et j'ai été diagnostiquée en effet l'an passé du trouble de la personnalité borderline. Et le trouble en fait est arrivé de façon très subite dans ma vie lorsque j'avais dix-huit ans.
Donc contrairement à d'autres personnes où c'est arrivé au fur et à mesure, eh bien moi, pour ma part, du jour au lendemain, lorsque j'avais dix-huit ans, j'ai commencé à avoir de nombreux symptômes et c'était très fort.
Donc, je peux peut-être énumérer directement un peu les symptômes que j'ai vécus.
Ouais, donc dans ton expérience personnelle quoi. Donc tu dis vraiment du jour au lendemain,
C'est ça, ouais
...à dix-huit ans, qu'est-ce que t'as ressenti à ce moment-là ?
Donc en fait, pour mettre un petit peu de contexte, je suis française et j'ai vécu en France, en Belgique, puis au Brésil.
D'accord.
Et pendant que j'étais au Brésil, j'ai été en couple avec quelqu'un et ensuite on a décidé de faire une relation à distance.
Mmm-hmm.
Et puis ensuite on a décidé qu'il vienne faire ses études en Belgique pour moi, pour me retrouver.
Et en fait, quand il est arrivé, je me suis sentie complètement bloquée et coincée par ce choix-là, avec une pensée intrusive de l'ordre de : comment faire si un jour je veux rompre ?
Je ne peux pas, je suis prise au piège parce qu'il est venu pour moi, donc c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas possible. Et cette pensée intrusive est vraiment...
Elle est relativement lucide, cette pensée-là.
Oui, elle est tout à fait lucide, sauf qu'elle m'a, au même titre qu'un toc, je pense que c'était vraiment de l'ordre du toc, elle était en permanence dans ma tête.
Et en fait, j'ai switché en quelques jours. Donc il est arrivé en juin, il y a un peu plus de dix ans du coup.
Et en fait du jour au lendemain, j'ai commencé à ressentir de la colère. J'ai commencé à l'idéaliser et puis ensuite à le dévaloriser.
On va en reparler, ouais.
Et plein de choses et vraiment tout s'est passé en fait comme ça quoi. Je m'y attendais pas du tout, je—
Ouais
...me sentais pas concernée.
Pensée relativement lucide, mais plutôt que de voir ça comme un problème, bon, qui te presse dans un coin de l'esprit, peut-être à, voilà, régler, voir comment est-ce qu'on peut résoudre ce problème-là.
Ça, c'était non-stop en boucle.
Ouais, il faut que je réponde maintenant à cette question : est-ce que j'ai envie de rompre avec lui ou pas ? Est-ce que j'aurais envie de rompre avec lui un jour ou pas ?
Parce que si oui, un jour, il faut que j'arrête tout de suite quoi, pour pas lui faire du mal. Il est venu pour moi et c'était sans cesse, c'était en boucle dans ma tête et c'était insupportable quoi.
Mais du coup, il faut que tu me dises. Est-ce que t'as rompu avec lui après deux jours ou... ?
J'ai rompu avec lui, c'était horrible, après trois semaines.
Ok.
Et euh...
Ça va, t'as tenu trois semaines.
Oui. Et en plus—
T'es tenace
...je l'ai trompé juste avant de rompre parce que au moins, la tromperie, c'était quelque chose de définitif. On pouvait pas revenir en arrière.
C'était quelque chose, 'fin, avec mes valeurs en tout cas, c'était un non négociable. Et du coup—
J'aime bien comment tu parles de valeurs en disant que tu l'as trompé.
C'était tellement pas en adéquation avec mes valeurs que du coup, on ne pouvait pas revenir en arrière. Il n'y avait plus de doute et je me suis dit que tout allait bien se passer après avoir rompu.
Et en fait, ça a été que le début de la descente aux enfers, honnêtement.
Qu'est-ce que tu veux dire par la descente aux enfers ?
Ben du coup, donc les symptômes ont été de plus en plus présents pendant que j'étais encore avec lui pendant ce mois de juin.
Et j'ai rompu et je me suis dit : « Maintenant, c'est bon, c'était juste ça et je vais revenir à la normale. » Sauf qu'en fait, il y a eu quelque chose qui s'est passé.
Ah oui. T'as pas arrêté d'être borderline après avoir rompu.
Oui, voilà, c'est exactement ça, ouais. Les symptômes, ils se sont développés et en fait, je me suis rendu compte, mais je le savais pas à l'époque, je l'avais pas conscientisé, que j'avais une gigantesque dépendance affective.
Et donc en fait, soit j'étais seule, donc célibataire, mais du coup, j'avais, genre cette dépendance affective me rongeait, je me sentais profondément seule.
Du coup, qu'est-ce que je faisais ? Ben traquer les hommes, on peut dire, pour être en couple avec quelqu'un. Et en fait, c'était rebelote.
À chaque fois que je me remettais en couple,
je me reposais des questions. J'étais clairement concernée par le TOC du couple aussi, en me demandant si l'autre personne est le bon choix, si je devrais pas plutôt être avec quelqu'un d'autre, etc.
Et donc finalement, je rompais et rebelote.
Ok. Quand tu disais tu traquais les hommes, c'était vraiment en mode la chasse quoi.
Non, j'exagère quand même, mais je faisais ma liste de courses quoi. Je regardais la personne et je me disais, à la Tinder quoi.
Je me disais : est-ce que cette personne pourrait me convenir ? Il y a ça qui va bien, il y a ça qui va bien. Allez hop, on essaye.
Ouais, donc—
Et voilà quoi.
Donc de nouveau une pensée quand même très— une petite fixation là-dessus quoi.
Ouais ouais ouais, de ouf. Ouais, non, c'était vraim—
Une grosse fixation.
Ah ouais ouais, non, énormément. Ma vie était en fonction— 'fin même mes années, comment je les définis, c'est en fonction d'avec qui j'ai été quoi.
2014, c'est telle personne, 2015, telle personne. 'Fin, c'est défini en fonction des— dans le passé, plus maintenant, mais en fonction des relations amoureuses que j'ai pu avoir, ouais.
Ok ok. Et donc dans ce que tu viens de dire, les symptômes, on a donc ce que tu disais par rapport à l'attachement et puis la diabolisation presque, le—
Dévalorisation.
Ouais, dévalorisation complète de l'autre personne.
Ouais.
La pensée très, limite l'obsession quoi, le—
Ouais ouais ouais.
La pensée très...
Très obsessionnelle, ouais, tout à fait.
Un autre truc que j'ai manqué dans ce que tu viens d'évoquer ?
Oui oui oui, il y en a beaucoup beaucoup de symptômes. Donc déjà, c'était vraiment un style d'attachement qui était très désorganisé, en fait.
Ça veut dire que du coup, au début, je veux fusionner avec la personne. Donc là, il y a vraiment
le côté fusionnel. Et puis dès que finalement, on fusionne, là, finalement, j'en veux pas, je rejette, je me sens en insécurité et du coup, c'est moi qui rejette.
Donc c'est vraiment très spécifique du style d'attachement désorganisé. Et sinon, en fait, j'ai vraiment été concernée par les neuf symptômes du trouble borderline.
Donc, il y avait cette peur de l'abandon, mais extrême. Quitte à aller jusqu'au point d'anticiper l'abandon et d'abandonner avant d'être abandonné pour être tranquille.
Il y avait des changements d'humeur ultimes. Donc il peut vraiment y avoir le fait de me sentir hyper de bonne humeur le matin.
Et puis juste parce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui dit quelque chose et que je me sens inconsidérée, par exemple,
je peux me transformer complètement et là, devenir un monstre qui pense vraiment des bêtises de moi-même et des autres.
Un monstre, c'est sévère quand même.
Ah ouais, non, c'est vraiment en mode genre je ne mérite pas d'exister. Pourquoi est-ce que j'existe ?
Tu te percevais, tu te percevais comme tel.
Ah oui oui oui oui oui.
C'est ça. Tu ne te juges pas maintenant, à l'époque. Tu parles de comment tu te percevais à l'époque.
Ouais ouais ouais.
Ok ok.
C'était vraiment une émotion de désespoir, en fait, qui était très présente de : ma vie ne mérite pas d'être vécue, je ne mérite pas d'exister.
Les autres aussi, d'ailleurs, sont nuls.
Ne méritent pas d'exister
Non, pas à ce point-là. Mais c'était, ouais, c'était quand même très, ben très fort, en fait, très intense.
C'est ça qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs dans le trouble borderline. C'est vraiment majoritairement beaucoup d'instabilité quoi.
Et d'intensité, ouais.
Et beaucoup d'intensité, ouais, c'est ça quoi.
Ouais, et tu disais, mérite pas d'exister. Est-ce que ça allait jusqu'à des idées suicidaires, des choses comme ça ?
Alors du coup, ouais, ça allait clairement jusqu'à des idées suicidaires, même si je n'ai jamais passé le pas. Bien qu'on rappelle que quatre— 'fin non, je dis.
80 % des gens qui ont le trouble borderline, qui souffrent de ce trouble, tentent de se suicider. C'est énorme, c'est entre 70 et 80 %, donc c'est gigantesque.
Et 10 % en effet,
décèdent alors qu'ils souffrent du trouble. Donc c'est vraiment des chiffres catastrophiques. Pour ma part, paradoxalement, c'est très étrange ce que je vais dire, mais j'ai toujours eu très très peur de la mort depuis toute petite.
Et j'ai pu analyser en fait pourquoi est-ce que j'avais autant peur de la mort, c'est parce que je voyais la mort, ou plutôt l'après-mort, comme un abandon.
Je suis morte, donc je ne suis plus avec les autres. Je suis abandonnée, je suis seule pour toujours. Donc, il y avait déjà en fait cette peur ultime de l'abandon et de la solitude.
Du coup, j'avais extrêmement peur de ce qui allait se passer après la mort. Et c'est paradoxalement cela qui m'a tenue en vie, puisque cela m'a empêchée de commettre
un suicide, parce que j'avais de toute façon beaucoup trop peur de ce qui allait se passer après.
Mais par contre, j'ai été en effet concernée par beaucoup d'automutilation. Donc voilà, je me suis plus d'une fois automutilée, il y a de nombreuses années, pour plusieurs raisons.
La première, c'était parce qu'honnêtement, mes émotions étaient tellement insupportables que du coup, le fait de se concentrer sur une douleur physique permettait de diminuer à court terme la douleur mentale.
Mais c'était aussi pour me punir d'exister, pour me punir d'avoir trompé, par exemple, mon copain de l'époque ou pour me punir pour mes actes.
Et enfin, c'était aussi, dans une certaine mesure, pour me victimiser. Donc pour qu'en fait la marque ensuite soit visible et qu'on s'inquiète pour moi et qu'on me rassure.
Donc, il y avait un besoin de validation émotionnelle.
C'est fascinant parce qu'à mon avis, il y a pas mal de gens qui nous écoutent qui tout d'un coup comprennent pas mal de choses sur les personnes qu'ils ont pu rencontrer par le passé, y compris moi.
Mais donc, automutilation, pensées suicidaires, qui étaient donc en partie dues à, voilà, des idées très fortes, très intenses, ouais, les émotions dont on parle là.
Et puis en plus de ça, le truc de : mais je suis pas comme il faut, je suis un peu un monstre, qu'est-ce qui va pas avec moi ?
Je devrais pas— tellement pas normal que je devrais pas exister quoi. Il y a un petit peu tout ce truc-là qui se mélange.
La culpabilité de : mais pourquoi je fais ça ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Et je me suis beaucoup demandé : est-ce que je suis pas une manipulatrice, une perverse narcissique ?
J'ai ce besoin comme ça de désirer. Je sentais bien, je voyais bien que c'était hyper important pour moi de me sentir désirable.
Mais ensuite, une fois que je voyais que je plaisais à la personne, là, j'en voulais plus, donc je rejetais. 'Fin, c'était ignoble et je conscientisais que j'avais ces comportements, mais c'était plus fort que moi.
Donc il y avait vraiment quelque chose de l'ordre de : t'es qu'une connasse quoi Fio, c'est horrible ce que tu fais aux autres quoi.
Et donc tu ne devrais peut-être même plus parler aux gens pour leur propre bien-être quoi.
Mh. Mh. Ouais, donc quand tu dis ça, forcément, ça me fait penser, ça fait écho à ce que moi, je connais de plutôt l'autisme où là, il y a aussi pas mal de suicides.
Je crois qu'on a sept fois plus de chances de se suicider quand on est— de faire une tentative de suicide.
Quand on est autiste par rapport aux neurotypiques. Mais là, c'est plutôt vraiment dû au stigma et au fait qu'on se sent pas comme il faut, bizarre et on—
Cassé, ouais, je dirais—
Ouais, ouais. Donc ça se rejoint un peu et en même temps, c'est aussi assez différent. Je pense que, ouais, on n'arrive pas aux chiffres dont tu parlais—
Ouais
...vis-à-vis des tendances de suicide. Quoi d'autre comme trait, tu disais, il y en a neuf ?
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Donc là, on a déjà dit qu'il y avait la peur de l'abandon, les changements d'humeur, la tendance à idéaliser et dévaloriser l'autre.
On a aussi parlé de l'automutilation et/ou des envies suicidaires.
L'impulsivité un peu dans ce que tu as dit aussi.
L'impulsivité, ouais, tout à fait. Donc le fait de, un peu comme on retrouve d'ailleurs dans le TDAH,
le fait de vouloir suivre ses pulsions pour se sentir vivre en fait, parce que si on n'est pas impulsif, on va passer par un autre symptôme qui est un peu l'inverse, c'est la sensation de vide.
Donc il peut vraiment y avoir cette sensation de ne rien ressentir, de se sentir complètement vide, d'avoir l'impression de ne pas vraiment exister.
Et du coup, on va alors faire des actions impulsives, donc typiquement remplies d'adrénaline et/ou de dopamine pour ressentir à nouveau des choses.
Parce que c'est ça l'avantage qu'on a quand on souffre d'un trouble borderline, c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin de drogues pour ressentir des choses très fortes.
Parfois, je peux me sentir hyper incroyable et franchement hyper puissante et surhumaine juste parce que je suis en up quoi.
Et ça, ça fait partie du coup du symptôme suivant qui est vraiment, autant je parlais d'idéalisation, dévalorisation de l'autre, ça peut être aussi de soi quoi.
Donc je peux passer de je suis incroyable, je fais des choses sublimes à, comme je disais, je ne mérite pas de vivre, je suis un monstre.
Pourquoi est-ce que j'entreprends tout ça quoi ?
C'est cette
dualité, j'allais dire bipolarité, mais justement parce qu'il y a pas mal de personnes qui, je pense, vont un peu mélanger ce que tu viens de décrire avec le trouble bipolaire en se disant :
oui, il y a des moments où j'ai envie de mourir et d'autres moments où je me sens génial, ben je dois être bipolaire.
Ouais, ouais, ouais. Mais néanmoins, il y a des grandes différences avec le trouble bipolaire. La première déjà, c'est que
dans la plupart des personnes qui souffrent du trouble bipolaire, c'est des phases qui vont durer plus longtemps, avec des phases du coup de dépression et qui vont durer vraiment
plusieurs semaines en général, voire plusieurs mois, avec de l'autre côté des phases de manie ou d'hypomanie, mais où en gros, on est en hype, mais comme je le disais, qui vont durer plus longtemps.
Et le seul cas de figure où c'est plus court dans le trouble bipolaire, c'est la cyclothymie, où là, en effet, c'est beaucoup plus court, comme dans le trouble borderline.
Mais ce qui va vraiment faire la différence, c'est que la cyclothymie, c'est quelque chose de l'ordre de la chimie qui fait qu'on va avoir ces changements d'humeur,
alors que dans le trouble borderline, il y a toujours quelque chose qui fait qu'on va changer d'humeur.
Donc soit quelque chose de l'ordre de l'extérieur, d'un événement extérieur qui s'est produit, qui va faire que,
comme je disais, je suis hyper bien et puis là, il y a quelqu'un qui me coupe la parole et je commence à partir dans des pensées intrusives de l'ordre de
: OK, cette personne-là, elle ne m'aime pas et d'ailleurs personne ne m'aime et d'ailleurs, moi non plus, je m'aime pas.
Et d'ailleurs, je ne devrais pas exister. Sauf que ces pensées-là, elles s'enchaînent en quelques secondes et il y a une hyperréactivité émotionnelle extrêmement forte.
Donc c'est vraiment ça qui va faire la différence. Et donc il y a cet événement extérieur ou ces pensées intrusives et/ou qui vont faire qu'on switche dans le trouble borderline.
Donc quand ton cerveau va parcourir un petit, je sais pas, un chemin neuronal qui va toucher aux émotions, qui va toucher à des ressentis forts, ça va aller très vite, ça va s'accélérer à fond.
Ouais.
Alors que côté bipolaire, ça va plutôt être, ben je sais pas, un petit bug chimique quelque part qui va faire qu'on va arriver sur ce terrain-là.
C'est ça, ouais. Je sais pas quelles sont les hormones qui sont concernées pour le trouble bipolaire, mais je sais que pour le trouble borderline, en fait, c'est vraiment au niveau de l'amygdale qui est une partie dans le cerveau.
Toujours elle.
Oui, toujours elle, qui va donc être hyperactivée émotionnellement. Enfin, il va y avoir une hyperactivation et en plus, après, il va y avoir une difficulté à redescendre.
Donc ça va aller très très vite, très très fort et plus longtemps quoi. Donc quelqu'un de classique qui ne serait pas concerné par le trouble, ça va prendre un petit peu et puis ça va redescendre tranquillement.
Alors que pour ma part, ça m'est déjà arrivé de mettre cinq heures à redescendre où je suis en mode hyper, toute tremblante et c'est vraiment difficile de me calmer quoi.
Mh. Mh mh. Donc ça, c'est, voilà, niveau les émotions très intenses.
Ouais.
D'autres traits qui te viennent ?
Oui.
Je pense qu'on va parler de paranoïa aussi.
Oui, voilà, c'est ça. Tout à fait. C'est le symptôme qui est le plus grave dans le sens où on dit souvent qu'il est présent dans des cas de stress intense
et on met ensemble d'ailleurs la paranoïa et la dissociation, ce qui n'est pas logique parce que ce sont deux symptômes complètement différents par lesquels j'ai pu également être concernée.
Ouais ? T'as des exemples de situations où t'étais un peu trop paranoïaque ?
Donc paranoïaque, moi, ce serait typiquement quand il y a quelque chose qui est anormal, qui est un peu bizarre.
J'en sais rien, je suis au stand-up. Là, j'étais à un spectacle de stand-up samedi et le gars fait son spectacle et c'est un peu atypique.
C'est, la manière dont il joue est un peu bizarre.
OK.
Et en fait, je commence à me dire qu'il y a un truc qui cloche et je commence à me dire : est-ce que je suis dans la vraie vie ?
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas quelque chose ? Est-ce que les gens ne sont pas contre moi ?
OK, OK.
Est-ce que je suis pas dans la matrice ?
Mais tout ce que tu disais sur le parallèle avec la dissociation alors où-
Alors du coup, la dissociation, là, c'est encore différent.
Ouais, ouais, mais parce que tu disais, euh : est-ce que je suis dans la vraie vie ? Tu vois, enfin il y a un côté, tu te demandes si ta perception de la réalité est la bonne.
Oui, c'est là, oui, peut-être, oui, en effet, le rapprochement qu'il y aurait les deux, c'est qu'on se rapproche un peu plus du côté psychose, en fait.
Quand je suis concernée par la paranoïa, enfin quand je l'étais, je sais néanmoins quand même que je paranoïe. J'en suis consciente.
Donc c'est pas la psychose comme on pourrait en retrouver
potentiellement dans la schizophrénie par exemple.
Là, voilà, je suis au supermarché, je vois des gens qui me regardent, j'ai l'impression qu'il y a quelque chose qui va pas, mais j'arrive à conscientiser que, ben Fio,
t'es fatiguée, il faut juste que tu rentres chez toi et que tu dormes et tu sais que ça va passer dans vingt minutes et tu sais que tout va bien donc c'est ok.
Là où une personne schizophrène qui est vraiment en train de perdre contact avec la réalité n'a pas forcément ce réflexe-là et n'est pas forcément consciente du fait qu'elle est en train de délirer.
Exactement, ouais, c'est ça.
Et dans la dissociation du coup, donc là, c'est le principe donc, on a plusieurs
sortes de dissociations, mais on parle surtout de dépersonnalisation et de déréalisation qui sont deux formes de dissociation
où du coup en fait, il y a un moment donc dans le trouble borderline, là, ça va être, je vais peut-être un peu plus parler du côté neurologique.
Je t'en prie.
Avec du coup la fenêtre de tolérance et avec les différentes branches du système nerveux.
Donc quand l'être humain se sent relativement en sécurité,
il est dans-- on dit qu'il est dans son système nerveux parasympathique ventral, et que donc du coup ben voilà, il se sent en sécurité et du coup, il est plus enclin à pouvoir parler aux autres et se sentir bien avec les gens.
Et puis les choses vont faire que peut-être à cause d'un événement extérieur, il va être ce qu'on appelle être activé au niveau du système nerveux sympathique.
Et là du coup, il va y avoir une sécrétion de certaines hormones comme l'adrénaline, le cortisol et la noradrénaline. Et c'est dans ces moments-là qu'on parle de certaines réponses traumatiques comme
tu as peut-être déjà entendu parler du fight or flight.
Bien sûr ouais.
Fight or flight ou freeze, voilà. Donc dans le sympathique, ben là, on va avoir tendance soit à se mettre en colère, soit à fuir.
Et puis si en effet, à un moment, c'est trop fort, il va y avoir la sécrétion d'une autre hormone qui est l'endorphine. Et là cette fois-ci, on va comme tu dis si bien, freeze.
Donc on va se retrouver en état de dissociation. Il y a d'ailleurs une autre réponse traumatique qui est moins connue qui s'appelle aussi le fawning.
En gros, c'est le principe du people pleasing où on va complètement s'adapter à l'autre pour plaire, pour être sûr de ne pas avoir de conflit avec cette personne.
Mais si on en revient du coup à la dissociation, on va donc avoir tendance à vraiment se protéger en fait de l'environnement qu'on considère comme insécurisant.
Et donc dans la déréalisation, on va avoir tendance à voir l'environnement comme un peu flou comme ça, un peu en mode brouillard.
On a l'impression de le voir un peu au travers d'une caméra. Et si on parle de dépersonnalisation, là, c'est plutôt, ben de se sentir pas très connecté à son corps pour en fait se protéger de cet environnement qu'on
valorise, enfin qu'on sent comme insécurisant quoi.
Pas très connecté à son corps, donc ça va jusqu'à se voir comme une autre personne ou se voir de l'extérieur ou comment est-ce que-- est-ce que toi, tu l'as vécu ça ?
Ouais alors donc moi, la dissociation, c'est mon symptôme le plus fort justement.
Encore aujourd'hui ouais.
Encore aujourd'hui ouais, même si c'est déjà beaucoup moins fort qu'avant, mais ça diminue petit à petit, ça prend beaucoup de temps d'en sortir.
Donc il y a en effet la dépersonnalisation, on peut se sentir en dehors de son corps. Donc ça, moi, ça m'est arrivé une seule fois au moment où le trouble borderline s'est manifesté à dix-huit ans, où vraiment, je me suis vue quoi,
en train d'engueuler mon copain de l'époque et lui jeter des carottes à la gueule.
Super, super histoire. Et il y a la déréalisation où en effet,
ben même encore aujourd'hui, même si ça commence à aller mieux, quand je me regarde dans le miroir ou quand je regarde mes mains, c'est pas que je vois quelqu'un d'autre, c'est que je n'arrive pas à sentir que c'est moi quoi.
Et pareil quand je regarde mes proches, j'arrive pas à sentir que c'est eux. Je sais que c'est eux parce que de nouveau, je ne suis pas concernée par des problèmes de psychose.
Donc je sais consciemment que ce sont eux. Je sais que je suis moi, mais en termes de sensation, je ne me sens pas quoi. Je ne me-
OK, tu arrives à rationaliser le truc, à te rappeler que c'est eux.
Oui.
Mais tu dois te le rappeler quoi.
Ouais.
Parce que si tu te fies juste à tes instincts, à tes sensations, à tes sens, euh...
C'est peut-être pas eux quoi.
Et c'est très désagréable surtout comme sensation.
J'ai juste envie de revenir sur ce que je disais parce qu'on parlait de la différence avec les personnes schizophrènes en disant qu'elles n'étaient pas forcément en mesure de réaliser qu'elles sont en plein délire.
Elles peuvent être en situation où elles le réalisent pas, mais elles peuvent aussi être en situation où elles réalisent hein.
Je pense que les personnes qui entendent des voix peuvent capter que les voix sont pas vraiment là.
Oui, tout à fait quoi.
Donc c'est ouais, je voulais juste nuancer ça un petit peu à ce niveau-là.
Et d'ailleurs, les gens qui ont le trouble schizophrène n'entendent pas forcément des voix quoi.
Bien sûr ouais.
C'est aussi quelque chose à nuancer.
Oui. Nom de-- ouais, j'ai un, voilà, oui, c'est ça. Un politicien en particulier qui employait beaucoup cette expression et je l'ai corrigé en live.
C'est oui, les gens qui pensent que ça veut dire avoir deux personnalités en fait, deux personnes dans une même tête, ce n'est pas du tout ça.
Oui, c'est ça. Et là, dans ce cas-là, ce serait d'ailleurs plutôt le trouble dissociatif de l'identité où en effet, on a les différents alters quoi.
Ouais, c'est ça. Oui, ça existe aussi. Tiens d'ailleurs, justement, un autre symptôme que j'ai noté : changement d'identité.
Oui. Ben du coup, le changement d'identité, c'est vraiment plutôt par rapport à la perception de soi quoi.
OK.
Donc ça peut être vraiment que un jour, je me dis que je suis super bien dans ma vie et que c'est exactement ce qu'il me faut.
Mh.
Et puis quelques heures plus tard, je vais remettre tout en question en me disant : mais pourquoi j'habite ici ? Pourquoi je fais ce travail ?
Pourquoi je sors avec cette personne ? Pourquoi est-ce que je fais tout ça ? Ça ne me correspond pas du tout quoi.
Est-ce que tu pourrais être genre révolutionnaire communiste le matin et puis le soir devenir super facho ou euh ?
Je pense pas que j'aille jusque-là quand même, mais ça peut quand même vraiment vraiment changer quoi.
OK, OK, OK. Ça va. Peut-être pas jusque-là.
Pas jusque-là.
Euh, OK. Est-ce qu'on a fait le tour des symptômes du coup ?
Oui, je crois. Il y a la colère aussi hein, j'en ai pas beaucoup parlé, mais donc il y a en effet des excès de colère, euh...
OK. Quand tu jettes des carottes sur les gens parce que tu les as trompés par exemple.
Quoi ?
Quand tu jettes des carottes sur les gens parce que tu les as trompés par exemple.
Voilà. C'était avant.
Ah ça va alors.
Mais ouais, ça peut être vraiment euh... En fait quand on se sent-- moi en l'occurrence, c'est par rapport à l'inconsidération.
Si je me sens inconsidérée, ça, il y a vraiment un switch dans ma tête. Enfin maintenant, ça va beaucoup mieux, mais ça va être vraiment, je me transforme en fait.
Et enfin, j'ai vraiment l'impression de me transformer. C'est un switch.
Mh.
Et là je pète un câble et ça me demande beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de self-control pour réussir à garder mon calme et ne pas dire euh-- enfin, j'ai déjà dit des trucs, mais ignobles quoi, qu'heureusement, heureusement, j'ai évolué depuis.
Mais ouais, ça peut être euh...
Des trucs que tu pensais vraiment ou bien des trucs où t'avais juste envie de blesser l'autre personne et t'as dit des choses que tu pensais pas ?
Ah non, c'est ça le pire, c'est que sur le moment même, je le pense vraiment, ouais. Je le pense ouais.
Mais et avant et après, tu le pensais pas ?
Oui, c'est ça ouais. Du coup, par exemple, j'ai déjà dit à un copain il y a de nombreuses années que c'était qu'un incapable, par exemple, et qu'il n'était rien d'autre qu'un incapable.
C'était horrible.
Mais est-ce qu'au fond de toi, tu pensais pas vraiment qu'il était incapable ?
Ben au moment même, oui, mais c'est ce que je pensais. Mais dans la vie de tous les jours, non. Enfin, toute personne a quand même des qualités euh.
Oui, c'est ça.
Voilà quoi. Donc non, mais au moment même, en fait, c'est ça, on perd toute temporalité. Et donc du coup, au moment même
Oui ok, on rationalise pas forcément les choses.
Pas du tout. En fait, l'émotionnel est tellement puissant. Maintenant, du coup, ça va beaucoup mieux, mais l'émotionnel au moment même est tellement, tellement puissant qu'on en oublie la rationalité et on en oublie la temporalité.
Et donc même si la veille, on a passé un super bon moment
et que ça arrivera à nouveau, là, au moment
même, par exemple, si j'ai pas de complicité avec mon copain et qu'on s'engueule,
ben et que je suis pas attirée par lui, par exemple, au moment T, ben je vais oublier qu'hier, j'étais attirée par lui et qu'on s'est dit je t'aime ou que sais-je.
Et juste là, à l'instant T, de façon émotionnelle, je vais remettre en question la relation parce que là, à l'instant T, ça ne va pas quoi.
Et c'est très très très fort et ça demande beaucoup beaucoup d'introspection sur soi pour réussir à faire la part des choses quoi.
Mais on va parler un petit peu des besoins spécifiques, des choses qu'on peut mettre en place pour un petit peu gérer ça au quotidien. Je pense que
beaucoup de personnes qui-- tiens d'ailleurs, est-ce que tu penses qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont borderline, mais qui sont juste pas au courant, qui ont ce trouble, mais qui l'ont pas forcément diagnostiqué ?
Oui, je pense qu'il y en a vraiment beaucoup. Oui, je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes qui sont concernées par ce trouble et que c'est dur.
Parce qu'en fait, c'est ça qui est compliqué avec ce trouble, c'est qu'au-delà, ok, il y a des symptômes qui sont très spécifiques comme la dissociation et
l'automutilation, ce sont des choses qui sont vraiment extrêmement fortes, mais le reste des symptômes, tout le monde peut être concerné par la peur de l'abandon, tout le monde peut être concerné par des changements d'humeur.
Le nombre de fois d'ailleurs où j'explique les symptômes, encore quelqu'un m'a dit il y a pas longtemps : oh, mais ça va, ça, c'est pas vraiment un trouble.
Parce qu'ils se rendent pas compte en fait de l'intensité. En fait, c'est ça qui fait la différence, c'est l'intensité quoi.
C'est un petit peu comme quand moi, je fais la liste des traits autistiques et que les gens disent : bon enfin, tout le monde est un peu autiste.
Oui, c'est ça. C'est tellement invalidant en fait quand la personne se rend pas compte, je crois que même, elle essaye d'inclure en fait en disant : mais c'est pas si grave ce que tu as, t'inquiète pas, t'es pas vraiment malade.
Mais en fait non, toi, tu ne te rends pas compte en fait de ce que je vis au quotidien.
Oui ou alors carrément dans l'autre situation, la personne est autiste, mais elle, elle est pas au courant et donc elle pense que mais non, mais tout le monde est comme ça.
Ouais.
Tout le monde regarde par terre quand on parle aux gens. Enfin, c'est quoi le souci ?
Oui, c'est vrai. Ouais, ça, c'est un autre sujet.
Mais donc ouais, les besoins, les choses qu'on peut mettre en pl-- que tu as mises en place, parce que tu disais que c'est un symptôme dont tu parlais, mais au passé, d'autres présents.
Est-ce qu'il y a des choses que tu as mises en place pour faire disparaître, par exemple-
Alors euh...
Les excès de colère, par exemple, le fait de plus désidéaliser une personne complètement. Est-ce que t'as des choses que tu as pu gérer ?
Alors, n'hésite pas à me couper parce que ça va être très très long sinon, parce que c'est la partie en plus que je préfère, donc voilà.
Je pense que déjà, la première chose, c'est que ça prend énormément de temps.
Donc pour qui que ce soit qui m'écouterait, voilà, c'est clairement, il y a pas de changement qui se fait comme ça, bam, du jour au lendemain.
Ça demande énormément de temps, de patience et de bienveillance envers soi-même.
Je pense qu'avant tout en fait, et pour moi d'ailleurs, le diagnostic,
donc ça fait qu'un an que j'ai été diagnostiquée, mais je pense que tout le travail, ça fait dix ans que je travaille sur moi pour aller mieux, mais le travail, c'est surtout cette dernière année qui s'est fait.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'en fait, ce diagnostic, ça a été franchement une-- ça a été horrible parce que ça a été en fait vraiment comprendre que c'est mes comportements qui sont toxiques.
Donc on rappelle que ton diagnostic est finalement assez récent. Tu dis que ça fait à peu près un an.
Oui, c'est ça. Un peu plus d'un an. Et c'est vraiment ce diagnostic qui pour moi a été très révélateur de vraiment me dire mais waouh, en fait chacun a ses comportements toxiques, chacun est responsable de ses émotions.
Et moi-même, en fait, moi qui avais tendance à beaucoup m'idéaliser quand même et à être un peu narcissique du style moi, j'ai compris la vie, l'hygiène de vie, c'est hyper important.
J'ai compris qu'en fait, j'avais des comportements toxiques à crever, notamment dans les relations amoureuses et que j'avais clairement du travail à faire sur moi.
Donc la première chose, je pense que c'est vraiment déjà d'accepter en fait qu'on a des difficultés et qu'on a du travail sur soi à faire et d'arrêter de rendre responsables les autres en fait.
Et tout ça, tu l'as fait avant ou après le diagnostic ? Qu'est-ce qui t'a amenée sur le chemin du diagnostic à la base en fait ?
Alors, ce qui m'a amenée du coup, c'est que d'abord-
Parce qu'on parlait des gens qui le sont, mais qui sont pas du tout au courant et qui ont pas du tout quelqu'un autour d'eux pour leur dire que peut-être, ça ressemble un petit peu à un trouble borderline.
Oui, c'est ça. Et c'est pas facile d'ailleurs à dire aux gens : je pense que t'es conc- enfin, c'est un trouble qui en plus est très stigmatisé.
Donc dire ça à quelqu'un, c'est difficile. Donc pour ma part, j'ai d'abord été diag-- donc quand j'ai compris que ça n'allait pas à dix-huit ans, j'ai directement été voir des médecins et des psys.
Donc on m'a-- donc j'ai compris le mot angoisse à ce moment-là, parce que je connaissais pas le mot angoisse.
J'ai quand même été concernée par des crises d'angoisse très très fortes aussi à dix-huit ans, avec sensation de mort imminente.
Donc c'était quand même très très fort. Et donc on m'a d'abord diagnostiqué un trouble anxieux généralisé et on m'a mise sous antidépresseurs pendant un an et demi.
D'accord.
Donc ça, c'était au début.
Ça, t'as aimé ou c'était bof ou ?
Je regrette pas dans le sens où je savais pas faire sans et que
honnêtement, je vivais de façon angoissée en permanence et je me sentais coincée dans la vie parce que, entre guillemets, je rêvais de me suicider, mais c'était pas possible parce que j'avais trop peur de ce qui se passait après la mort.
Et en même temps, vivre était angoissant parce que je savais qu'un jour, j'allais mourir. Donc c'était hyper paradoxal et c'était vraiment difficile.
Donc le fait d'avoir les antidépresseurs qui ont diminué mes symptômes était nécessaire, mais ça n'a absolument pas résolu le problème de base.
Donc j'aime bien l'idée de voir les antidépresseurs comme une béquille, mais qui ne résout pas le problème de fond et qu'il est important de résoudre le problème de fond, notamment en thérapie.
Mais ouais, quand tu dis les médicaments qu'on t'avait donnés contre l'anxiété, c'était genre Xanax, tout ça ou ?
Non, non, c'était des antidépresseurs.
Antidépresseurs, ok.
Pas des anxiolytiques.
C'est ça ouais, ok, ok.
Ouais, ouais. Donc les premières semaines ont accentué encore plus mes symptômes. Parce que c'est ce qui est connu dans les antidépresseurs.
Et ensuite, ils ont permis de les diminuer. Mais du coup, j'avais d'autres effets secondaires comme une perte de la libido,
des problèmes de mémoire, des problèmes de concentration, des mauvais mélanges avec l'alcool et je buvais quand même beaucoup d'alcool à l'époque. Donc-
On va en parler.
Oui. Donc ouais. Mais ce que j'ai beaucoup apprécié, autant j'ai pas toujours apprécié les rendez-vous que j'avais avec mon psychiatre parce que j'avais l'impression qu'il me donnait les médicaments comme des bonbons.
J'avais partagé le fait par exemple que j'avais une phobie de l'avion. Il m'avait donné de la benzodiazépine très facilement, que heureusement, je n'ai pas prise.
Mais ce que j'ai apprécié, c'est quand même qu'il fixe. Je pense que quand on a un trouble, notamment borderline, on a besoin d'un cadre.
Et j'ai beaucoup apprécié le fait qu'on fixe les antidépresseurs, c'est pour un an et demi et dans un an et demi, on en reparle pour les diminuer et les arrêter.
Et c'est exactement ce que j'ai fait quoi. Et le fait d'avoir ça, qui était vraiment fixé, ben ça m'a permis-- ça m'a fait du bien d'avoir ce cadre déjà.
Ouais, mais ce cadre-là, sans pour autant être face à un professionnel de santé qui sait reconnaître le borderline ou qui sait te donner des indications par rapport à ça.
Ça, c'est un autre sujet dans le sens où en effet, à l'époque, j'ai quand même parlé de dissociation-
Mh.
Parce que j'avais trouvé le terme sur Internet tout simplement. Et donc j'ai dit que j'étais concernée par l'automutilation, par la dissociation, donc qui sont des symptômes très spécifiques du trouble borderline.
Et on m'a uniquement diagnostiqué un trouble anxieux généralisé. Pour moi, c'est-- qui dit dissociation dit trauma.
Mh.
Et trauma, y a, 'fin y a,
y a le trouble de stress post-traumatique simple ou complexe, y a le trouble borderline. Mais 'fin un trouble anxieux, sans vouloir minimiser ce trouble-là, c'est trop léger par rapport à ce que je pouvais vivre en termes de symptômes quoi.
Y a plus qu'un trouble anxieux généralisé à partir du moment où je partage des symptômes aussi forts quoi.
Mais je comprends que voilà, que j'ai vécu cette errance due au fait que les professionnels de la santé étaient pas forcément formés, en fait, tout simplement.
Voilà, c'est tout le problème hein.
Et voilà, c'est pas contre eux. 'Fin ils ont pas délibérément ne pas voulu me diagnostiquer ou autre, mais c'est vrai que ça a été dur.
Et par la suite, en fait, j'ai fait des tests et j'ai su que j'étais haut potentiel-
Mh.
Et hypersensible. Donc là, je me suis dit qu'OK, ça me permettait de mieux comprendre. Et j'ai continué en fait de faire beaucoup d'introspection en lisant beaucoup de livres de développement personnel.
Et en fait, je voyais en couple notamment que ça n'allait pas, en fait. Je voyais que ça n'allait pas du tout. Et je lisais du coup des livres sur les HP et l'amour pour essayer de mieux comprendre et je ne trouvais rien.
Et puis je suis tombée en fait sur le TDAH et je me suis reconnue dans les symptômes.
Mh.
J'ai fait un diagnostic et du coup, j'ai été diagnostiquée borderline à la place du TDAH, sans pour autant exclure le TDAH, mais la neuropsychologue et ensuite le psychiatre-
Ont dit que, ben les symptômes qui en tout cas étaient le plus présents étaient bien les symptômes du trouble borderline, sans pour autant exclure les symptômes-
Oui.
Du TDAH.
C'est ça le truc hein, c'est qu'on peut empiler différents diagnostics et que souvent, on a tendance un petit peu à en repérer qu'un seul et puis
éventuellement mélanger tout ça dans une grosse soupe et dire : ''Oui, tu es HP, voilà.'' Et puis on-
Voilà.
Voilà, la subtilité, c'est pour les autres. Plus précisément, tu disais en couple, tu voyais que ça allait toujours pas.
Donc c'était toujours des histoires de, avec cette colère, gros attachement et puis rejet quand-
Ouais.
La personne était trop proche, tout ça.
Idéalisation, dévalorisation-
Oui.
Style d'attachement désorganisé, ouais, envie de fusionner. Et puis finalement, je rejette, j'avais tendance vraiment à courir après quelqu'un, en général, je veux dire, qui est très fuyant.
Mh.
Et puis quand finalement, il baisse sa garde et il me dit : ''Mais Fio, je t'aime, c'est bon.'' Moi, je lui disais : ''Wo wo wo, en fait, moi, je sais pas trop.
Donc je vais partir, ça va.'' 'Fin voilà, j'extrapole, mais 'fin tu vois, c'est ce style-là quoi.
Pour info, j'étais dans la place de l'autre personne qui se faisait courir après, puis : ''Mh, pas trop.''
Ouais, ouais, mais c'est-
C'est ça.
Ouais, c'est pas très... Des deux côtés, voilà.
C'est pas top. Donc ouais, un petit peu errance diagnostique pendant quelques-- mais 10 ans, c'est quand même long hein.
Ouais, 10 ans, ouais.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que ça a duré 10 ans ?
Parce que c'est vrai que j'ai vu des psys hein. Pendant 10 ans, j'ai vu plein de psys différents. J'ai testé plein de techniques différentes, d'hypnose, de constellation familiale.
Comme je disais, ouais, je pense que c'est vraiment le fait que les psys ne sont pas assez formés.
Informés, mh.
Peut-être aussi que beaucoup-- peut-être, est-ce que certains, peut-être, ne se posaient pas la question me concernant, mais qu'ils n'osaient pas le dire par peur de mettre une étiquette ?
Pour ma part, moi, l'étiquette, elle m'a fait du bien. Elle m'a permis, comme je disais, de comprendre mes comportements toxiques et de pouvoir travailler là-dessus et de travailler sur ma dépendance affective.
Non, moi, je pense que c'était-- Je me rappelle par exemple qu'avec une de mes psys, je lui partageais mes difficultés en couple en disant : ''Mais j'ai des doutes, mais atroces.
Je doute en permanence toute la journée de si je devrais pas rompre avec l'autre.'' En fait, j'étais concernée par le TOC du couple hein, du coup, à ce moment-là, mais j'en avais aucune conscience.
Et elle m'avait répondu : ''Oh, mais vous savez, c'est normal, tout le monde a des doutes.'' Et d'autres personnes me disaient : ''Oh, mais si tu as des doutes, c'est que ce n'est pas le bon parce que t'es censée,
t'es censée ressentir en permanence de la jouissance ou que sais-je.''
Ok.
Alors qu'en fait, non quoi.
Ouais, peut-être des professionnels, des psys qui avaient peut-être juste un petit paragraphe sur le trouble borderline dans leur-
Tout à fait.
Dans leur master et qui se tenaient à un truc très très, très très précis. Et en fait, la notion de spectre, la notion d'un petit peu, voilà, on est tous un petit peu différents à ce niveau-là.
Je pense, ouais.
Et pas tellement comprise.
Peut-être aussi que sur le côté, comme mine de rien, on en reparlera après, j'avais une très bonne hygiène de vie.
Mh.
J'étais stable dans le sens où ben voilà, j'ai un boulot, je-- tout ce genre de choses.
Tu disais que tu buvais énormément d'alcool.
Oui, 'fin énormément,
Énormément. Des montagnes de bière, tu me disais.
J'aime pas la bière en plus. Non, mais c'est vrai que je buvais quand même. J'ai eu une période vraiment vers mes 20 ans où, ben comme je disais, vivre était vraiment atroce.
Et du coup, c'était tous les soirs-
D'accord, compensation quoi.
Compensation. Je sors jusqu'à 6 h du mat'. Je suis pas bourrée dans un état où je me rappelle pas de la soirée non plus, mais quand même, j'ai quand même des blackouts et je bois toute la soirée.
Et puis on est reparti le lendemain, je dors en journée quoi, et puis on est reparti le lendemain soir.
Ok.
Donc quand même-
C'est pas la meilleure hygiène de vie hein.
Non, c'est pas du tout.
Parce que tu disais à l'instant que-
Non, non, après.
Ok, d'accord.
Après, j'avais une très bonne hygiène de vie quoi.
Ok, donc à un moment, spontanément, tu t'es calmée au niveau de l'alcool ?
Alors là en l'occurrence d'ailleurs, je fais un an sans alcool hein. Donc là ça fait six mois que j'ai pas bu. Sinon ça fait trois ans que je fais un mois sans alcool, le Dry January.
Donc là évidemment, il y a clairement eu une évolution. Mais sinon pour moi, je pense que ce qui a vraiment changé la donne,
c'est en fait quand j'ai arrêté mes études de pharmacie en troisième année, ça a été très très dur pour moi parce que j'ai vu ça comme un échec.
Et puis je savais pas du tout ce que j'allais faire de ma vie du coup, sans diplôme. Alors que j'avais quand même reçu une éducation vraiment de, en gros, si t'as pas de diplôme, tu vas finir caissière.
En gros, c'était ça que j'ai reçu comme éducation. Et en fait, le fait de-- à ce moment-là, mes parents ont dit : « Bah, tu viens nous retrouver à Lyon, là où nous on habite ».
Et moi, j'ai dit : « Non, je reste à Bruxelles, quoi ». Et je sais pas pourquoi, je voulais en plus, je sais pas, je voulais rester à Bruxelles.
Donc ils ont dit : « OK, mais tu te gères financièrement alors ». Et en fait, pour moi, ça a été le déclic. J'ai trouvé un boulot en tant que vendeuse dans un magasin de jeux de société.
OK, donc pas tout à fait caissière, mais...
Donc pas. Et étant passionnée des jeux. Et en fait, ça a été pour moi le premier déclic de, je crois que c'était ce côté où je me sentais, ben justement considérée et utile.
J'avais un cadre, donc on comptait sur moi en journée et le fait en fait d'avoir tout ça, genre, je peux pas sortir jusqu'à cinq heures du mat', on m'attend le lendemain au boulot quoi.
Et ça a été pour moi la première chose de devoir me gérer. Je peux pas faire autrement, je dois me gérer.
Ça a été vraiment le premier truc où vraiment j'ai commencé, j'ai l'impression, à remonter quoi.
Et un boulot qui te passionnait en plus et que tu devais pas faire à contrecoeur en traînant les pieds.
Oui, ben après, je suis partie au bout d'un an et demi parce que-
Parce que t'es quand même borderline, ouais.
Parce que j'ai besoin de changement tout le temps. Et là, je suis en train de rechanger de boulot d'ailleurs, mais j'en parlerai sûrement après.
Mais en tout cas, ouais, le fait d'avoir quelque chose ou en tout cas que ça ait du sens en fait. Il y a ce besoin, je sais pas si c'est propre aux troubles borderline, mais moi, j'ai ce besoin d'avoir de l'impact, d'avoir du sens dans ma vie.
C'est propre à la génération Z, ça plutôt, non ?
Peut-être, ouais.
Au niveau de-- parce que bon, je sais pas si on a terminé au niveau de ce qu'on met en place pour gérer-
Pas du tout.
On n'a pas du tout terminé, ouais.
On n'est qu'au début, là.
Oui ok, ok pardon. Je t'ai trop interrompue, mais vas-y. Vas-y, tu peux partir dans ton monologue et je t'écoute.
N'hésite pas à me couper hein, parce que vraiment, il y a beaucoup de choses. Donc du coup, en effet, il y avait, ben déjà le cadre de vie, la structure.
Et après, ça a été vraiment la deuxième chose,
ça a été vraiment l'hygiène de vie quoi. Donc vraiment avoir une bonne hygiène de vie, arrêter de procrastiner, donc faire les choses quand elles doivent être faites, d'une façon très cadrée, très structurée.
Quand je pense à quelque chose, je le note pour pas l'oublier, les post-it, ce genre de trucs. Le sport, pour ma part, moi, c'est cinq fois par semaine.
La méditation, donc j'ai suivi une formation de pleine conscience et je médite et/ou je fais du breathwork ou du yoga ou de ce genre-là tous les jours pour vraiment apprendre à défusionner de mes pensées.
Donc ça, ça a été vraiment des life changers, diminuer, voire arrêter l'alcool, huit heures de sommeil, bien manger. Tout ça, c'est des trucs-- je sais que ça peut paraître con parce qu'entre guillemets, tout le monde en parle.
Non, c'est essentiel.
C'est hyper essentiel parce qu'en fait, pour ma part en tout cas, si je fais pas tout ça, mon amygdale, elle part en fait.
Et je suis prise par ce truc émotionnel. Et en fait, c'est uniquement en ayant une hygiène de vie limite hors pair que du coup, j'arrive à avoir vraiment cette analyse de mes émotions quoi.
Je sens ce qui se passe en moi grâce à la méditation. Je sais exactement quand est-ce que j'ai envie de pleurer, quand est-ce que j'ai faim, quand est-ce que j'ai besoin de dormir, quand est-ce que là, je me sens un petit peu triste, nostalgique.
N'importe, toutes les émotions, je sens, je sais ce qui se passe, je sais quel est mon besoin
et je peux du coup défusionner en me rappelant que c'est un besoin qui est, par exemple, 'fin, qui a quelque chose d'émotionnel, mais que pour autant, je dois pas remettre en question ma vie quoi.
Et je vois quand est-ce que je pars dans mes pensées intrusives et donc je peux défusionner de tout ça quoi.
Et par exemple, on parlait de l'anxiété tout à l'heure ou l'angoisse.
Ouais.
Tu vois ça arriver-
Exact.
Tu le sens, mais tu fais quoi du coup ?
Ben du coup, donc ma dernière crise d'angoisse réelle, elle date pardon de décembre 2018.
Pas mal.
Et depuis, j'ai déjà été angoissée, bien sûr, à nouveau, mais je sens l'angoisse arriver et je sais ce que je dois faire, c'est-à-dire, et c'est le plus dur, lâcher prise, accepter qu'elle va arriver.
'Fin, lâcher prise dessus et même limite souvent lui parler en lui disant : « Ben coucou toi, je te laisse ta place déjà.
Je vais pas essayer de t'enfuir là en buvant de l'alcool ou que sais-je. Non, non, je te laisse ta place. Tu es là pour me dire quelque chose, je t'écoute.
Et surtout, si jamais ça devait encore être une crise d'angoisse, c'est OK. D'ailleurs, je sais que ça me rendra plus forte.
Donc c'est cool. Je vois ça comme une expérience de vie pour, ben en permanence m'aider à gagner en maturité émotionnelle.
Et juste, ben je te laisse ta place et j'attends que ça passe parce que je sais que ça passera et ça passera toujours et que je vais pas en mourir en fait ».
Mh.
Et le fait de me rappeler ça, ça change tout quoi.
Donc ça, c'est vraiment vis-à-vis des émotions et de pas se laisser complètement, ben plus qu'envahir, mais leur donner le contrôle complet.
Voilà, maintenant, tu gères un peu plus, tu leur laisses la place, mais tu te laisses pas non plus écraser, envahir complètement.
Ouais.
Vis-à-vis, par exemple, de la gestion des relations, par exemple avec tes copains, par exemple que tu trompes, par exemple sur lesquels tu jettes des carottes.
Tu-- comment est-ce que tu vois, ben voilà, tout ce qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure en fait hein, le fait que tu
veux les gens qui veulent pas forcément de toi, puis tu les idéalises très fort et puis,
et puis finalement, bon ben non, en fait non, tu m'intéresses plus du tout ou des frustrations énormes par rapport à des différences par rapport à ce que tu idéalises, etc.
Ça-- est-ce que t'as pu progresser à ce niveau-là ou ça reste compliqué ?
La première chose que j'ai faite déjà, c'est de vraiment travailler sur ma dépendance affective et du coup, de passer du temps seule.
Donc là, actuellement, je suis célibataire et du coup, là où avant, je savais pas tenir plus de deux semaines, là, ça fait genre sept mois, ce qui pour moi est gigantesque.
Et encore, techniquement, ça fait un an que je suis célibataire, genre vraiment, genre plus en couple. Donc il y avait vraiment ce truc de
j'arrête de draguer quelqu'un, j'arrête d'aller sur les applications de rencontres, j'arrête toutes ces bêtises.
Et vraiment, je prends le temps de m'accueillir, de m'accepter pleinement, de m'aimer, d'avoir des projets hyper importants, je trouve, d'avoir des projets qui ont du sens pour moi,
de vraiment laisser place à toute mon ambition qui est assez gigantesque de tout ce que j'ai envie de mettre en place dans ma vie, en fait,
au-delà du couple, où en effet, clairement, le couple, c'est quelque chose d'hyper important pour moi, mais il y a pas que ça quoi.
Donc ça, ça a été et c'est toujours un chemin hein, je suis pas, ça y est maintenant guérie et tout. Non, ça se fait petit à petit.
Donc ça, c'est une chose. Et puis de l'autre côté, ben en effet, il va y avoir, je pense que pour moi, ça passe beaucoup par en fait la communication non violente quoi.
Donc c'est vraiment le fait de, qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Tu lui achètes plus de carottes.
Je lui achète plus de carottes. Je-- non, c'est vraiment genre le fait de, ouais, de en fait partager les choses à l'autre, en défusionnant, 'fin, en prenant du recul en fait et en partageant mes besoins.
Mh. La communication finalement.
Ouais.
Et de pas accuser l'autre en fait et de pas changer. Ça, c'est pour moi, je pense que ce dans quoi je suis maintenant et c'est le plus dur, c'est vraiment de m'accepter avec mes failles et mon imperfection.
Ça, c'est quelque chose de très difficile pour moi et d'accepter du coup l'autre et les autres, les amis aussi et les proches, la famille, etc.
comme ils et elles sont aussi quoi, avec leurs imperfections et de voir leurs imperfections, de voir leurs défauts et de pas chercher à vouloir tout modifier pour que ce soit comme moi, j'en ai envie quoi.
Ouais. Mais clairement, là, tu montres, 'fin, je suis pas là pour commenter, mais 'fin beaucoup de travail, beaucoup d'introspection, beaucoup de maturité au niveau de
ton senti et tes exigences par rapport aux gens qui sont autour de toi.
Donc t'as surtout parlé du fait que t'es célibataire depuis à peu près un an. Mais par exemple, pour les amis, t'as aussi encore des difficultés par rapport à ça ?
Oui, oui, oui. La plus grosse difficulté que j'ai, c'est que j'ai besoin de discussions profondes.
Ok.
Et que du coup, lorsque c'est pas assez profond, j'ai-- c'est compliqué pour moi et donc je m'ennuie en fait en la présence de mes amis.
Est-ce que je peux réagir à ce que tu viens de dire ?
Vas-y.
Tu sais ce que je vais dire ou pas ?
Non.
Ben le small talk, c'est un truc que les autistes détestent.
Oui.
Voilà.
Et enfin après, c'est-- je crois que les gens qui ont un TDAH aussi, 'fin beaucoup de personnes en gros neuroatypiques-
Beaucoup de personnes qui ont un TDAH sont aussi autistes, oui, c'est ça que tu veux dire ?
Quoi, tu penses que c'est vraiment spécifique à l'autisme ?
Non, parce que je suis sûr qu'on peut trouver des neuroatypiques qui trouvent ça chiant. Enfin, c'est, voilà. Mais c'est quand même très-
Ouais.
Ouais, 'fin, voilà. Mais ça va, vas-y continue.
C'est pour ça que je me pose des questions aussi sur les troubles autistiques puisque je me suis rendu compte que vraiment
quand quelqu'un me raconte quelque chose et que ce n'est pas stimulant, c'est vraiment ça, j'ai pu me rendre compte au fur et à mesure de ces dernières années, ça me demande un effort surhumain de rester concentrée, ne serait-ce qu'une minute.
Je dois utiliser toutes mes ressources. Je prends quelque chose dans mes mains pour bouger, mais vraiment, c'est très très très difficile-
Ouais, ok.
Et je donne du mieux de ma personne.
Donc, mais ce que tu dis là, c'est peut-être pas forcément spécifique au small talk ou au truc superficiel, mais juste, je sais pas si je fais un monologue maintenant sur un vieux jeu vidéo des années 80 et que ça t'intéresse pas.
Peut-être, oui.
Tu vas aussi, voilà, ce sera pas du small talk, mais tu voilà.
C'est aussi le manque d'intérêt, ouais.
Donc là, c'est plus TDAH du coup. Je te fais ton diagnostic au fur et à mesure du podcast.
Parfait, super, je prends des notes. Et mais il y a en effet ce-- en gros, quand je m'ennuie, quand je manque d'intérêt et que je m'ennuie-
Ouais, ouais.
Je suis quelqu'un de très rapide aussi, 'fin, vu que je fais beaucoup beaucoup de sport, j'ai une très très bonne condition physique et du coup mes amis n'arrivent pas à me suivre quand je marche.
Et en fait, le fait de devoir aller lentement, c'est vraiment difficile, 'fin plus lentement que ma marche.
Pour marcher ?
Ouais.
Ouais, ok.
Et en fait, c'est vraiment dur pour moi.
Hyperactivité du coup.
Hyperactivité, ouais, complètement quoi.
TDAH, ouais.
Et TDAH. Et du coup, ben en fait, dans ces moments-là, donc je passe par de l'ennui et autant m'ennuyer seule de mon côté, ça va, mais m'ennuyer avec des gens, là, c'est plus compliqué parce que j'ai des pensées intrusives.
Je-- alors dans ce cas-là, autant méditer quoi. Mais je peux pas parce que la personne me parle et donc il faut que je l'écoute.
C'est quoi les pensées intrusives quand tu t'ennuies avec les gens ?
Ben du coup, là, ça va devenir : mais pourquoi je suis amie avec cette personne ? Et puis ensuite, je vais me dire : Fio, t'es en train de dévaloriser la personne.
C'est un des symptômes du trouble borderline. Reviens à l'instant présent.
Ok.
Et puis ensuite, 'fin voilà quoi.
Mais donc vraiment d'où l'importance d'un diagnostic quoi.
Exact.
D'arriver à se comprendre soi-même, être en contact avec son propre fonctionnement et d'arriver à voir : ok, c'est ça qui se passe.
Ouais.
Je vais peut-être temporiser un petit peu mon ressenti quoi.
Ouais, c'est exactement ça. Et de vraiment me dire : bon ben là, j'ai pas passé un super bon moment avec ce ou cette ami, mais c'est aujourd'hui.
Ce podcasteur-là qui n'arrête pas de me diagnostiquer.
Ça va pour le moment. J'étais déjà un peu au courant de ces diags.
Oui, oui, je sais. On en a parlé juste avant de lancer l'enregistrement. Je rassure les gens qui nous écoutent.
Donc non, c'est encore difficile, mais petit à petit, on va dire que ça va de mieux en mieux quoi.
Ok, cool.
On va dire ça comme ça.
Et donc on parlait de tout ce qu'on peut mettre en place. Donc on a parlé gestion des émotions, gestion des relations amoureuses, amitiés, etc.
Ouais, la thérapie, évidemment aussi.
Bien sûr, oui. Donc t'as parlé de la méditation.
Ouais.
Des trucs plus spécifiques au niveau de la thérapie ?
Oui, oui, oui. Du coup, oui, il y a vraiment des thérapies qui ont été prouvées de façon scientifique pour
fonctionner sur le trouble borderline, dont notamment la TCD, donc la thérapie comportementale et dialectique, qui est un dérivé de la TCC, thérapie comportementale et cognitive.
Donc de la TCD qui a été en fait créée par, je vais essayer de pas écorcher le nom, Marsha Linehan, dans les années 80, 90,
qui est une personne concernée et psychologue
et qui a mis en place en fait cette thérapie qui est axée justement ben sur la pleine conscience, la tolérance aux émotions fortes, la régulation émotionnelle et la gestion des relations pour apprendre à mieux gérer le trouble au quotidien.
Mais il y a d'autres thérapies aussi, comme la thérapie des schémas par exemple, et la thérapie basée sur la mentalisation, que je connais moins.
Et également, moi, je pratique en ce moment deux autres thérapies, puisque le trouble borderline est en général, on n'a pas beaucoup parlé encore des causes du trouble borderline, mais il y a souvent-
On va en parler, on va en parler, ouais.
Il y a beaucoup de traumas et du coup, il y a des thérapies comme l'EMDR et la Somatic Experiencing, que moi, je pratique en alternance une semaine l'une, une semaine l'autre en ce moment, qui peuvent aider du coup à se libérer de certains traumas quoi.
à se libérer de certains traumas quoi.
Ok. Et alors, peut-être vis-à-vis de ce qu'on disait sur la dépersonnalisation, éventuellement la dissociation, éventuellement la paranoïa, là, il y a des trucs qui te viennent en tête ?
Ben alors oui, du coup, oui. En fait, qui dit dissociation dit trauma, hein, ça, c'est vraiment hyper connecté.
Et du coup, ben là, moi, je dissocie beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup moins fort ces derniers mois par rapport à depuis dix ans quand même.
Et donc t'as commencé ça depuis quelques mois alors ?
Ces deux thérapies, ouais.
Ok.
J'ai commencé ces deux thérapies et également, j'ai commencé, ben l'arrêt de l'alcool, qui m'a grandement aidée. Je ne suis plus en couple, ça m'a grandement aidée.
Et surtout le breathwork, qui est du coup une technique de respiration contrôlée où on a tendance à hyperventiler.
Et en fait, moi, ça m'a vraiment changé la vie de faire le breathwork parce que ça m'a permis de petit à petit me sentir de plus en plus en sécurité avec mon corps, en fait.
Et du coup, qui dit se sentir plus en sécurité avec son corps dit du coup de moins en moins de dissociation. Et donc je vois vraiment une Ouais, c'est gigantesque par rapport à janvier, là, il y a cinq mois.
C'est vraiment, je me sens beaucoup mieux avec moi-même, beaucoup plus en sécurité dans mon corps quoi. Du coup, c'est ça qui est aussi hyper important quand on est concerné par un trouble borderline,
c'est vraiment d'écouter ses besoins et d'écouter son corps aussi, en fait, de vraiment se reconnecter à son corps quoi, et la pleine conscience.
Ok. Est-ce qu'on a terminé tous les trucs à mettre en place pour mieux gérer tous les symptômes ?
Parce que j'ai envie de parler des causes, mais...
Ok.
Ben sauf s'il y a encore des choses à rajouter.
Ben il y a quand même une chose sur laquelle je voudrais revenir.
Ok.
On en a un peu parlé, mais j'ai vraiment envie de mettre un point là-dessus.
L'hygiène de vie, je fais ça depuis un certain temps, comme je disais, le cadre aussi, ça m'a-- les deux et la thérapie, tout ça, ça m'a fait beaucoup de bien au fur et à mesure du temps.
Mais il y avait une chose fondamentale que je faisais pas assez avant et c'est vraiment l'accueil des émotions. C'est le fait qu'en fait, en tout cas moi-
Mmh-mmh.
Étant concernée par le trouble borderline, je passe vraiment par des laps de temps où je peux me sentir vraiment down et désespérée du coup.
Et dans ces moments-là, j'avais tendance à beaucoup me culpabiliser en me disant : « Mais enfin, pourquoi tu vas mal ? T'as tout pour aller bien, t'as ceci, t'as cela dans ta vie ».
Et en fait, le fait de vraiment accueillir ces émotions et d'accepter qu'il y a des moments où je vais mal, ça fait toute la différence.
Et de vraiment s'autoriser à pleurer, à extérioriser, à accueillir tout ce qui doit être accueilli. Pour moi, ça a été vraiment un des plus gros life changers de ma vie quoi.
Mmh. Donc vraiment pas forcément te dire : « Non, il faut positiver absolument. Ce que je ressens là, surtout l'effacer. Et non,
Surtout pas.
voir le verre à moitié plein. » Voilà, etc.
Pas du tout. C'est vraiment accueillir et me dire que ça fait partie de l'expérience et que je sais qu'ensuite, je me sentirai mieux quoi.
Ok. Donc c'est une meilleure expérience de juste laisser arriver l'énorme tristesse, l'énorme angoisse, la peur, la colère et tout ça, que d'essayer de minimiser, de dire que c'est pas besoin, pas besoin d'être en colère.
Ouais.
C'est bon, je peux gérer, je peux rationaliser.
Ouais, parce qu'en fait, on a tendance, quand on a une émotion qui arrive, on a vraiment tendance, en tant qu'humain, à vouloir la mettre de côté et à faire autre chose pour se distraire, ou à boire de l'alcool ou que sais-je.
Mmh-mmh.
Et parce qu'en fait, on a peur de cette émotion. Sauf qu'en fait, elle ne fait que grandir en nous. Un peu comme quelqu'un qui procrastine quoi.
Il va stresser en disant : « Ah,
il faut que je fasse ça, mais je le ferai plus tard, je le ferai plus tard ». Et en fait, c'est cette attente
qui est beaucoup plus dévastatrice que le moment où on va vraiment faire l'action si on procrastine ou le moment où on va vraiment accueillir cette émotion.
Pour ma part, le moment où je décide d'accueillir cette émotion, il va en effet y avoir un pic où pendant une demi-seconde, ça va être encore plus fort et très rapidement, ça va redescendre et je vais me sentir en fait beaucoup mieux quoi.
Et de vraiment prendre ce temps d'accueillir. Chaque fois, c'est la même chose quoi. Sur le moment, je me dis : « Ça va être une montagne ».
Et au bout de cinq minutes, j'ai pleuré toutes les larmes de mon corps et c'est bon, je suis repartie et je pars courir ou que sais-je quoi.
Ok, ok. Et donc tu disais que maintenant, t'as une très bonne hygiène de vie, que tu gères, etc. Donc la procrastination, je sais que tu faisais juste un parallèle hein, mais la procrastination, c'est absente de ta vie ?
T'arrives à vraiment gérer les choses comme il faut au poil ?
Franchement, quasi-- 'fin, j'ai eu un petit problème de chauffage. Là, j'ai procrastiné deux jours, mais sinon, hormis ça...
Ok.
Ouais, vraiment, j'ai vraiment mis en place, ouais, une organisation vraiment très rigoureuse en fait, parce qu'en fait cette sensation quand je procrastine est tellement insupportable-
Mmh.
que en fait, je ne ve-- Et surtout, ça ne sert à rien. 'Fin, c'est juste horrible comme sensation quoi, de procrastiner.
Que donc je préfère,
ouais, être rigoureuse et ça m'aide au quotidien en fait de vraiment-- Et j'ai appris à accepter que parfois, du coup, je peux paraître peut-être un peu rigide, mais en fait, ça me fait du bien d'avoir ce cadre,
même si en parallèle de ça, j'ai besoin aussi que le cadre évolue en permanence, que j'ai besoin de renouveau et j'ai besoin toujours de sortir de ma zone de confort.
Mais ça, c'est un autre sujet. Mais du coup, voilà, je suis en-- 'Fin, de toute façon, pour tout, je suis juste un paradoxe.
J'ai besoin de cadre en même temps.
Moi, je déraille un peu. Je fais vraiment n'importe quoi.
Je t'en prie, c'est-- On est là pour t'écouter. Ok, ben donc procrastination, tu dirais que ce serait--
Si tu te laissais aller, ce serait une envie que-- 'fin tu pourrais faire ça très naturellement, mais juste c'est tellement insupportable que t'as plus du tout envie dans la durée.
Ouais, et puis je crois que comme pour tout, c'est devenu une habitude en fait.
Mmh-mmh.
C'est vraiment devenu une habitude que j'aime bien cette petite règle : quand t'as un petit truc à faire qui prend moins de deux minutes, tu le fais directement.
Donc je le fais directement et sinon de le noter dans mes bloc-notes.
Mmh-mmh.
Et c'est devenu une habitude en fait de faire ça. Donc maintenant, même si je me laissais aller, il y a pas grand-chose qui se passerait parce que c'est comme si je me laissais aller, d'office que je ferais quand même du sport quoi.
Je parlais de ça parce que moi, c'est ma vie en fait. Je passe mon temps à procrastiner, j'arrive pas à passer à l'étape zéro.
Le truc que tu dis, ça prend deux minutes, je vais le faire.
Ouais.
Oui, ça prend deux minutes, je peux le faire plus tard.
Après, je comprends et je respecte. Il y a pas de jugement évidemment de ma part par rapport à ça hein.
Ok, ok. Et donc les causes, tu disais des choses liées éventuellement, 'fin souvent à des traumas. Est-ce qu'il y a des certitudes à ce niveau-là ?
Alors non, techniquement, il y a-- Pardon, vas-y, je t'en prie.
Non, non, je me fais lécher.
Par mon chat. Je précise au cas où.
Ben du coup, ouais, donc il y a en effet sep-- Les gens qui ont le trouble borderline, de ce que j'avais lu dans les dernières stats, mais qui changent un peu
d'une revue scientifique à une autre, il y a quand même septante pour cent des gens qui ont été concernés par des traumas.
C'est important quand même de rappeler qu'un trauma, c'est pas forcément quelque chose
de gigantesque que la personne a pu vivre, donc comme un viol ou une catastrophe naturelle, ça peut tout à fait être une suite de traumas répétés et même ça dépend du système nerveux de chacun, chacune.
Donc ça, c'est important de le rappeler. Donc en effet, il y a quand même pas mal de gens qui ont le trouble borderline, qui ont vécu des événements traumatiques, vécus comme traumatiques dans l'enfance, mais pas que.
D'après les sciences, il y aurait aussi le fait que déjà, de base, il pourrait y avoir quelque chose de génétique et/ou quelque chose au niveau de l'amygdale où en fait, il y a déjà une hypersensibilité depuis le plus jeune âge.
Et par exemple, quelque chose qui peut complètement intensifier un trouble borderline, ça va être justement un TDAH.
Parce que les personnes qui sont concernées par le TDAH, qui est un trouble neurodéveloppemental du coup, eh bien, ils vont avoir tendance-- Ça, ça peut arriver qu'on invalide leurs émotions dans l'enfance s'ils ont pas été diagnostiqués.
Parce que du coup on ne comprend pas ce qu'ils ont et on va peut-être par exemple les comparer à leurs frères et sœurs en disant : « Mais juste fais comme eux, fais comme elle ».
Et qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? Ben ça va-- du coup l'enfant va avoir l'impression que ses émotions sont invalidées et sont pas OK en fait.
Et du coup plus tard, cet enfant va développer un trouble borderline.
Peut le développer.
Peut développer par exemple, oui.
Non ok, ok. Mais donc on en revient au fait que ouais, plusieurs diagnostics qui s'empilent, qui se recroisent et qui amènent d'autres choses, etc.
Mais donc là tu menais vraiment un parcours très spécifique avec le TDAH.
Par exemple hein.
Ouais, ouais.
C'est 30 % je pense.
Mais tu parlais de toi en fait.
Non, moi, je ne sais pas. J'ai pas été diag, en tout cas.
Ok. Oui, oui, pas encore. Donc tu parlais d'un terrain génétique à la base plus des chocs qui peuvent être plus ou moins importants et qui déclenchent peut-être des petites reconfigurations au niveau de l'amygdale-
Ouais.
qui entraînent peut-être, voilà, une dérégulation des émotions et tout ça à l'âge-- alors déjà, est-ce qu'il y a un âge pour devenir borderline ?
Est-ce qu'on peut l'être déjà quand on est tout petit ou... ?
Alors tout petit, non, mais en effet, là, j'ai suivi une conférence la semaine passée où la psychiatre expliquait que désormais, on peut être diagnostiqué à partir de 14 ans, alors qu'avant, c'était 18.
Donc c'est quand même assez tôt, mais c'est pas non plus en effet-- quoi que cette psychiatre disait qu'elle se demandait si par la suite, le trouble borderline ne serait pas caractérisé comme un trouble neurodéveloppemental.
Bah oui, ben dans ce que tu-- oui, c'est-à-dire que neurodéveloppemental, il y a vraiment l'idée de on est né comme ça.
On est né comme ça quoi.
C'est ça, ouais, ouais.
Pour le trouble borderline, je pense qu'il y a l'hypersensibilité qui est présente depuis la naissance.
Mh.
Et que ensuite tout dépend de à quel point on va nous éduquer dans la famille à accueillir nos émotions, même si elles sont intenses et ce genre de choses quoi.
Ok. Et donc dans ton cas, est-ce que toi, tu as eu l'opportunité de réfléchir à tout ça ? Est-ce que tu te retrouves un petit peu dans l'explication que tu viens de donner ?
Ben moi, c'est vrai que depuis toute petite, j'ai quand même été concernée par une peur de l'après-mort. Du coup, vraiment, j'avais des crises, enfin, je savais pas encore à l'époque que c'était des crises d'angoisse.
Et je pense que, ben je me suis sentie incomprise. Je sais qu'à l'époque, plusieurs personnes ont essayé de m'aider, mais personne ne semblait avoir aussi peur que moi de la mort.
Et donc je me sentais d'autant plus incomprise. Et
en fait, cette peur n'a fait que grandir, grandir, grandir. Et à un moment, je l'ai intériorisée parce que de toute façon, je ne trouvais pas réponse à mes questions et que j'allais-- c'est à un moment ou un autre, ça allait arriver quand même.
C'est pas comme une phobie des requins ou juste, ben on va pas rencontrer de requins dans sa vie, potentiellement. Donc c'est OK.
Là, la mort, elle va arriver quoi qu'il arrive. Et donc j'ai tout intériorisé. Et pour moi, ben, le trouble, il allait apparaître d'une manière ou d'une autre quoi.
Ça a été cet élément déclencheur avec mon ex. Mais s'il y avait pas eu ça, il y aurait eu autre chose.
Et pour moi, le trouble, il est fortement relié quand j'en parle autour de moi, avec du coup cette peur ou plutôt cette sensation de non-mérite d'exister, d'inconsidération, de je ne mérite pas de vivre quoi, c'est vraiment ça.
Et ça, tu l'as eu par rapport à des choses qu'on a pu te dire ou bien vraiment de base, fondamentalement, de ton côté, t'as eu cette réflexion-là indépendamment des autres ?
Non, je pense qu'il y avait quand même quelque chose, ouais. Je pense que j'ai eu une enfance quand même difficile. J'ai subi du harcèlement scolaire.
Je me sentais toujours en décalage avec les autres.
Ouais, c'est ça. Donc stigmatisée pour une différence à la base.
Ouais, j'étais trop rapide. On me disait tout le temps que j'étais trop rapide. J'ai en effet dans les HPI, mon-- en termes de rapidité, je suis à cent cinquante, je crois.
Donc on m'a dit que c'était supérieur à 99,8 % des gens. Donc j'ai toujours senti un décalage au niveau de la rapidité, au niveau des émotions.
Dès que je voulais parler, dès que quelqu'un me disait quelque chose qui me blessait et que je voulais répondre, j'avais envie de pleurer.
Et donc j'arrivais pas à répondre parce que j'allais juste pleurer. Donc du coup, je prenais sur moi et en fait, je me sentais, dans ma sensibilité, je me sentais très très différente de la plupart des gens.
Mh, mh.
Et ça, je le ressens depuis le plus jeune âge et j'ai souvent eu l'impression qu'on m'ait dit que, ben voilà, que j'étais juste une enfant capricieuse et que j'avais des émotions trop fortes et qui n'avaient pas lieu d'être surtout quoi.
Donc là, pour le coup, c'est vraiment neurodéveloppemental. Ce à quoi on rajoute donc une couche de culpabilisation, de t'es pas comme il faut, etc.
Oui.
Un petit peu de mal-être.
Et puis on mélange tout ça et ça fait borderline quoi.
Quelque chose dans-
Potentiellement, ouais.
Ouais, potentiellement dans mon expérience personnelle, quelque chose de cet ordre-là, ouais.
Parce que moi, j'ai ça aussi, mais je suis pas borderline. D'ailleurs, j'ai l'impression que toutes les personnes borderline que je croise sont des filles. Mais je-
Ah ouais ?
Est-ce qu'il y a un peu un ratio à ce niveau-là ou ?
Alors, il y a un ratio en effet où on dit que c'est plus souvent des femmes, mais après, il y a aussi le questionnement de à quel point est-ce que ce sont plutôt des femmes qui font ce travail aussi d'introspection.
Mh.
Et du coup, c'est plus elles qui se font diagnostiquer quoi.
C'est un petit biais statistique.
Ouais.
Ouais, c'est ça ouais.
Je pense que c'est ce qui est dit dans les recherches scientifiques, ouais.
Ouais, ok, ok. Au niveau de, ben du coup, la stigmatisation justement.
Ouais.
Donc je t'ai entendu à un moment donné parler de souffrir du trouble, porter le trouble, etc. Et effectivement, dans les interviews qu'on peut trouver de toi en ligne, il y a beaucoup ces phrasés-là en fait, hein,
qui-- moi, quand on me parle de ça pour l'autisme,
je m'énerve rapidement parce que je trouve ça très stigmatisant justement, le fait de dire porteur d'un-- ben c'est pas si différent de t'es un petit monstre quoi.
Tu portes une marque, tu portes un stigmate, t'es pas comme il faut quoi.
Ben j'aime-- pour être sûre de voir là où tu veux en venir, moi, j'aime pas par exemple la phrase : « Je suis borderline ».
Je préfère dire : « Je souffre d'un trouble de l'identité borderline » par exemple.
Ok, ben là, on est fortement opposés à ce niveau-là.
Toi, tu dirais juste : « Je suis borderline » ?
Euh, ben alors, toi, tu connais beaucoup mieux le côté borderline que-- et moi, je connais beaucoup mieux le côté autisme, TDAH et tout ça.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Donc moi, je suis fortement du côté je suis TDAH, je suis autiste.
Ah ok. Ah c'est marrant, c'est intéressant.
Ok. Et donc toi, tu aurais fait la même chose pour le TDAH et pour l'autisme ?
Oui. Ben aussi d'ailleurs, je ne dis plus de quelqu'un qu'il est autistique, mais je dis qu'il souffre d'un trouble autistique ou qu'il est diagnostiqué d'un trouble autistique.
Je...
Tu vas y aller ?
Ouais, non, je-
Mais je vois-
Heureusement qu'il y a pas d'objets contondants sur cette table.
Mais c'est un-- en fait, pourquoi est-ce que je le formule de cette manière-là ?
Ok, je t'en prie.
Parce que je ne veux pas que la personne, moi compris, je trouve que dire : « Je suis borderline », c'est vraiment étiqueter la personne de borderline.
C'est la-- je ne veux pas que la personne soit uniquement son trouble en fait.
Soit résumée, ouais.
Soit résumée à son trouble.
Mais par exemple, si je te dis que t'es française, est-ce que tu te sens résumée au fait d'être française ?
Mais c'est-- 'fin, non OK, mais être française, c'est le terme-
J'ai préparé cet argument. Vas-y.
Genre je suis borderline, c'est pas-- ben non, c'est pas juste borderline, c'est en l'occurrence, c'est j'ai, alors plutôt j'ai un trouble de la personnalité borderline.
Donc ça, c'est la façon dont toi, tu le dis.
Ouais.
Mais t'aurais pas tendance à dire : « J'ai une nationalité française. »
Non.
Tu vois, il y a une petite contradiction là, non ?
Ouais, je réfléchis. Je sais-
Moi, je pense que quand on prend des-- alors c'est bizarre parce que je réponds à ma propre question, mais c'est un podcast, on est là pour discuter.
Quand on prend des gants et des pincettes pour dire personne en situation de handicap, personne porteur d'autisme et tout ça machin, il y a un petit peu un côté,
on va pousser le mot au bout de la phrase, on prend des gants parce que le mot est un peu sale quoi.
On n'a pas envie d'insulter la personne en lui disant, en l'associant avec le truc. Donc vraiment, on va insister sur le fait que c'est une construction sociale, c'est une question de situation, machin tout ça.
Mais au fond de ça, il y a l'idée que c'est un peu sale quoi.
Moi, je le vois pas comme quelque chose de sale. Je le vois comme quelque chose de, ouais, je ne veux pas que la personne ne soit que ça quoi.
Mais de nouveau-
Mais je comprends, j'entends ce que tu dis avec le « je suis française ».
Je ne suis pas qu'autiste, je ne suis pas que Belge et pourtant, tu vois, je ne suis pas que grand, c'est...
Pour moi, en fait, je crois que c'est une question par rapport au verbe quoi.
Une question sémantique, mais qui révèle beaucoup de choses, je pense.
C'est pas être, c'est avoir quoi, c'est avoir un trouble et pas être un trouble. C'est ça en fait.
C'est de distinguer la personne d'un attribut.
Oui.
Et donc dans certains cas, par exemple, voilà, la nationalité, hein, je reviens toujours dans ça.
Dans certains cas, tu trouves ça pas du tout un problème d'associer fondamentalement la personne, donc par essence, elle est Belge ou Française.
Mais par contre, pour un truc neurodéveloppemental avec lequel t'es né avant même d'avoir la nationalité française, tu te dis : « Je dois distinguer les deux. »
Et encore, c'est différent parce que le trouble borderline n'est pas un trouble neurodéveloppemental.
Ouais, ouais, c'est là que éventuellement, il y a peut-être un petit distinguo, c'est... Tu l'as attrapé à un moment donné, peut-être.
Oui, tu vois. Oui, j'aime bien cette idée d'attraper, tu vois, et de nouveau, j'aime bien aussi cette idée de ce n'est pas une sentence à vie.
Française, c'est une sentence à vie, techniquement.
Oui, parce qu'on n'a pas parlé de ça, mais le fait que ça disparaît petit à petit, 'fin ça s'atténue, ouais.
Ça peut, c'est-- donc ouais, ça s'atténue notamment avec l'âge, d'après les recherches scientifiques. Mais moi, je pense surtout que ça s'atténue parce qu'en fait, on apprend à se connaître
et qu'à mesure qu'on apprend à se connaître, on sait qu'est-ce qui est bon pour nous ou pas.
On arrête de faire des conneries en buvant plein d'alcool et on, voilà, on s'écoute en fait. On s'écoute et du coup, on sait plus quels sont nos besoins et on est plus mature aussi pour savoir partager nos besoins à autrui
et se respecter soi-même en fait.
Et donc j'aime bien cette idée de dire : « Ben je suis concernée, alors je suis concernée par le trouble de la personnalité borderline aujourd'hui.
» Ça veut pas dire forcément que je le serai toute ma vie quoi.
Ok, ok. J'ai souvent entendu parler de l'âge de quarante ans comme étant un moment où ça commence à se calmer, etc.
On a une idée de à quel point c'est vrai. Pourquoi est-ce que ce serait vrai ?
C'est-- honnêtement, j'ai entendu les mêmes choses et pareil quarante ans aussi et honnêtement, c'est pas très clair. J'ai quand même déjà entendu plein de témoignages de personnes qui ont plus de quarante ans et qui ont
toujours beaucoup de symptômes, mais qui n'étaient absolu-- en fait, moi, je pense que ce qui va surtout faire la différence, c'est ouais, c'est le fait de se connaître quoi.
Donc ce sont des personnes qui, par exemple, ont toujours les symptômes de façon très forte à plus de quarante ans, mais qui ne se connaissent absolument pas ou qui ne connaissent pas le trouble borderline et qui l'apprennent aujourd'hui.
Et je crois d'ailleurs à ces personnes, ce qui leur fait du bien, et là, pour moi, c'est vraiment le mot du podcast, c'est l'espoir, en fait.
C'est vraiment l'espoir, c'est le fait de se dire que, ben qu'on passe par des difficultés, mais qu'il y a un moyen d'aller mieux quoi.
De ce que j'ai lu dans les recherches scientifiques, avec l'âge de ce que j'avais lu, c'était un trouble qui tend à diminuer, surtout en termes de symptômes dans les actions.
C'est ce que j'avais vu. Donc les comportements suicidaires, les comportements impulsifs. Il va y avoir moins d'actions entreprises en rapport avec le trouble borderline.
Donc, je pense qu'il y a quand même une diminution. Mais sinon, en effet,
peut-être que moi, c'est d'une façon très extrême où je suis vraiment hyper investie en mode genre : « Ouais », parce que j'ai des grandes grandes ambitions dans ma vie, on va dire ça comme ça.
Mais je pense que déjà quelqu'un qui ne serait-ce que va entreprendre d'aller en thérapie, de faire un petit peu attention à ses heures de sommeil et de marcher régulièrement, ben c'est déjà super en fait.
Moi, c'est peut-être très extrême, mais voilà, je pense que déjà, en fait, le moindre petit pas est un pas en fait.
C'est vraiment comme ça que je le vois. Et surtout, en plus, le chemin vers le rétablissement n'est pas linéaire en fait.
Donc faut pas se dire qu'on évolue en permanence quoi.
C'est ça. Et dans ta bio Instagram, par exemple, tu mets rescapée du trouble de la personnalité borderline. C'est très fort de nouveau.
Ça-- donc tu vois vraiment ça avec, 'fin finalement, le trouble de la personnalité borderline, c'est l'ennemi quoi, c'est celui qui a failli te bouffer.
Alors, je pense que le trouble-- si on me disait : « Est-ce que tu peux... » 'fin Fio, si tu veux, on t'enlève, il t'est rien arrivé.
Tu peux ne jamais avoir eu le trouble borderline. Qu'est-ce que tu fais ? Je suis pas sûre que je l'enlèverais, tout simplement parce qu'il m'a appris énormément de choses.
Il m'a appris à avoir plus d'empathie envers les gens. Il m'a appris à moi à faire ce chemin introspectif et je pense que je serais quelqu'un de beaucoup plus égocentré et superficiel si j'avais pas eu ce trouble, honnêtement.
Donc, il m'a appris à avoir beaucoup plus d'humilité aussi. Donc je sais pas si je l'enlèverais, mais par contre, je le vois, moi, je me vois comme une survivante, c'est vrai.
Moi, je me vois comme c'est un miracle que je sois encore en vie.
D'accord.
Et je le vois vraiment comme je suis, et pas que moi, hein, toutes les personnes qui ont ce trouble, hein, je veux pas dire que je suis mieux que les autres, loin de là,
mais je suis, et nous sommes, toutes personnes concernées aussi, des réels battants.
Je dis souvent d'ailleurs sur Instagram le mot borderbattant, borderbattante, parce que je trouve que ça va bien ensemble.
Parce que c'est, c'est-
C'est un combat au quotidien.
Ouais, ouais, ouais, c'est vraiment un combat au quotidien, surtout dans les années les plus dures où, mais c'est atroce quoi, de passer par ces émotions.
J'en ai des frissons, c'est des émotions, mais qui sont tellement... 'fin, j'ai vu le avant, après aussi, donc je peux vraiment me rappeler avant d'avoir le trouble dans ma vie,
mes émotions étaient beaucoup moins fortes que ce que j'ai pu ressentir après, où c'est atroce quoi, c'est vraiment, c'est une horreur quoi, c'est une horreur, c'est pas possible.
Alors heureusement, ça passe, mais c'est, c'est dur et ça demande vraiment énormément de courage et de, ouais, de courage de quand même garder espoir en se disant : « Il y a un avenir meilleur quoi. »
C'est peut-être ça alors la différence principale, au niveau de ce qu'on disait, est-ce qu'on naît ou est-ce qu'on a ?
Là, t'en parles vraiment comme étant un combat, une difficulté, tu dis atroce. De manière générale, j'ai pas l'impression qu'il y a beaucoup d'autistes qui en parlent comme ça.
Oui.
Et du coup, ouais, du coup, je comprends peut-être cette envie d'un peu s'en séparer.
Ouais.
Et en même temps, tu dis : « J'aurais pas envie de, d'avoir vécu sans ». Donc tu l'inclues quand même très fort dans qui tu es.
Ouais, et puis surtout, ben en fait, ça m'a-- enfin pour moi, comme je te disais, c'est très important pour moi d'avoir un sens dans ma vie et un impact.
Et ce que j'ai envie de faire dans ma vie, sur du long terme, je sais que ça touche à, ben l'inclusion sociale,
à parler, déstigmatiser les troubles mentaux, à prendre ma place, à parler,
passer dans des interviews, faire des conférences, faire des formations en rapport avec le bien-être, en rapport avec la santé mentale, en rapport avec les troubles, en rapport avec la neuroatypie.
Et tout ça, ben je le dois à mon trouble. Je ne ferais pas ça si je n'avais pas eu mon trouble. Et donc d'avoir cette ambition, cette niaque par rapport à tout ça, ben je l'aurais pas si j'avais pas le trouble.
Donc du coup, dans un sens, je me dis : « Ben c'est cool si je peux
motiver ». Moi mon but, c'est de motiver les gens aussi qui ont le trouble en leur donnant de l'espoir, en les guidant un peu et en leur disant : « Battez-vous, y a vraiment moyen d'aller mieux ».
Et j'aime bien cette idée d'être un peu comme porte-parole en fait de tout ça quoi. Donc du coup, si le prix à payer est d'avoir le trouble aussi, ben je le prends quoi.
Et donc tu es forcément en contact avec plein d'autres personnes qui sont concernées au niveau du ratio entre les gens qui préfèrent dire « j'ai » et « je suis ».
Qu'est-ce que t'observes à ce niveau-là ?
Ça dépend.
Ouais, voilà, ouais.
Y a des deux. Des fois, je suis un peu trigger quand y a des gens qui aussi en jouent, qui utilisent beaucoup d'autodérision en disant : « Je suis borderline ».
Donc ça, c'est assez comique aussi. Genre j'en parlais avec un abonné y a pas longtemps qui disait qu'il faisait des trucs de dingue.
Il disait : « T'es borderline, t'es pas borderline ». C'est assez comique.
Là, ça devient limite un peu une excuse quoi aussi genre.
Oui, je suis d'accord.
Genre c'est des carottes chez mon copain, mais bon, je suis borderline.
C'est ça quoi. Tu comprends, j'ai le droit quoi. Donc non, j'entends un peu, j'entends les deux quoi.
Ok, ok, ok. Et donc tu parlais voilà de cette envie de faire des conférences, de parler, de t'exprimer, de mener vraiment un projet autour de la neurodiversité.
Ouais.
Et tu parlais du fait que tu changeais bientôt d'activité. Est-ce que les deux sont liés ?
Alors, donc déjà, maintenant, je suis devenue indépendante complémentaire avec Border Attitude-
Ok.
Le nom de mon compte Instagram, parce que je vends un e-book.
Oui, oui, oui.
Et que j'aimerais bien faire d'autres choses par la suite. Mais j'ai mis ça un petit peu en stand-by. Pourquoi ?
Parce que donc je change de travail la semaine prochaine. Donc, je travaillais avant toujours dans le secteur du jeu de société.
En gros, de fil en aiguille, j'ai changé cent fois de bureau dans ma boîte actuelle, enfin où je viens de démissionner là.
Je suis passée d'acheteuse à marketing, événementiel, design, etc. Et là, je change du coup et donc je vais rejoindre une société qui propose des formations en rapport avec le bien-être au travail.
Bah voilà.
Donc tout ce qui est développement organisationnel et personnel. Et notre plus gros client, justement, ce sont les institutions européennes.
Ok.
Donc il va falloir que je comprenne mieux la politique.
Bonne chance.
Merci. Et moi, je vais avoir du coup un bureau, un boulot assez multitasking avec du marketing, de la création de contenu pédagogique.
Et idéalement, l'idée, c'est que je devienne formatrice aussi quoi.
Ok. Donc avec, donc quoi, le Parlement européen, la Commission européenne, tout ça ?
Ouais, c'est ça.
Ok, ok, ok. Et donc tu disais, le e-book que tu vends, le-
Ouais.
Voilà. En plus de ça, donc ton compte Instagram qui est très actif.
Et mon site web.
Un site web, voilà, qui est donc ?
borderattitude.fr.
Voilà. D'autres choses que tu as envie de mettre en avant vis-à-vis de voilà, qu'est-ce que tu-- un petit peu ta méthode pour collecter les témoignages, les choses qui t'ont marqué un petit peu dans cette aventure-là ?
Je m'attendais pas à ce que ça prenne autant d'ampleur et à ce côté un peu communauté quoi. En fait, les gens, ça leur fait du bien de se sentir moins seuls quoi.
C'est surtout ça qui ressort, de se sentir compris, comprise, de se sentir moins seuls. Et je me suis rendu compte en fait à quel point,
ce trouble, ce diagnostic, il m'a permis de me rendre compte qu'en fait, j'étais tout à fait légitime dans ma différence et que tout le monde l'était aussi du coup.
Et que quand, par exemple, au bout d'une heure de réunion, j'ai besoin de me lever, même si ça, c'est pas spécifique au trouble borderline, mais j'ai besoin de me lever parce que j'arrive plus à me concentrer, ben j'ai le droit en fait à ça.
Au même titre que quelqu'un qui, je sais pas moi, a du diabète et a besoin de se faire une piqûre. Ben moi, j'ai besoin de ça en fait et je vois pas pourquoi j'aurais pas le droit de partager mon besoin.
Il est tout à fait légitime en fait. Il est là en fait. Et à partir du moment où je le ressens, ben j'ai le droit.
Alors bien sûr, après, c'est aussi important que je m'adapte à la société hein, je peux pas faire comme j'en ai envie, mais ça doit aller dans les deux sens en fait.
Mais donc ça demande que, par exemple, dans un contexte professionnel, tu en parles autour de toi, que tout le monde accepte, que tu assumes d'en parler publiquement, etc.
Ouais.
Tout le monde n'est pas forcément à l'aise ou n'a pas forcément le, j'allais dire le courage, mais les épaules pour entamer toute cette démarche-là quoi.
Ouais, et c'est ça que je trouve dommage, en fait. C'est ça que j'ai envie de pouvoir apporter dans ce monde. C'est ce côté où-
D'analyser un petit peu plus la neurodiversité quoi.
Ouais, et que ce soit normalisé, en fait, et que c'est OK d'aller méditer toutes les deux heures ou j'en sais rien quoi.
On va bientôt devoir se quitter. Est-ce qu'il y a un dernier point que tu aurais envie d'aborder ?
Oui, peut-être rajouter au niveau de la stigmatisation, que je sais que dans les témoignages que j'ai reçus, y a beaucoup de personnes qui me disent que,
ils et elles n'osent pas parler de leur diagnostic à leurs proches ou aux personnes-- elles se posent beaucoup de questions, par exemple, face à des nouvelles rencontres.
À quel moment est-ce que je parle de mon diagnostic ? Parce qu'en fait, ces personnes-là ont peur, et je comprends tout à fait, elles ont peur du regard de l'autre sur le trouble borderline.
C'est beaucoup plus facile de dire, je pense, qu'on est autiste ou un TDAH que le trouble borderline.
C'est, ou- alors oui, mais c'est aussi très, comment dire, c'est un gros mot quoi, c'est une insulte.
On se traite d'autiste dans la cour de récré, tu vois ce que je veux dire ? C'est...
Oui, c'est vrai, mais c'est encore pire, si je puis dire.
Ouais.
Quand le trouble borderline quoi, c'est vraiment la pire insulte, j'ai l'impression.
C'est pire et en même temps le mot est pas si connu que ça hein. Si t'en as pas entendu parler.
C'est vrai. C'est vrai que l'autiste est beaucoup plus connu.
Ouais.
Mais pour les gens, 'fin si-- le nombre de fois où des gens me disent qu'ils tapent sur Google « trouble borderline » et qu'est-ce qui apparaît, c'est « comment fuir une personne borderline ».
Son compte Instagram, on parle
Mon compte Instagram aussi. Mais sinon, « comment fuir une personne borderline », « les borderlines sont tous dangereux et manipulateurs », « ils sont dramatiques et en fait, ils cherchent juste de l'attention ».
Ok mais parlons-- 'fin oui, déjà ce que tu voulais dire par rapport à la stigmatisation.
Bah que du coup ça renforce encore plus en fait le sentiment de ne pas mériter d'exister et la culpabilité en fait, parce que les gens qui ont un trouble borderline ont-- sont vraiment les émotions les plus présentes.
Y a beaucoup de désespoir souvent, mais y a aussi beaucoup de honte, de honte d'exister et beaucoup de culpabilité du coup par rapport à ça.
Et le fait qu'en plus le trouble soit stigmatisé, ben ça renforce encore plus la culpabilité.
Et ça peut même aller au point que certaines personnes ne préfèrent même pas avoir des contacts sociaux pour se préserver par peur du coup de l'abandon, d'être abandonné, etc.
Ok, je pensais que t'allais dire pour préserver les autres, enfin ces gens-
Et pour préserver les autres, ouais, c'est ça ouais. Par peur, par peur de... 'Fin moi, je sais que j'ai eu un petit peu ça ces derniers mois où à un moment, je me disais
peut-être que c'est mieux que je reste célibataire toute ma vie pour préserver les autres quoi.
Mais par contre, il y a pas que des points négatifs quoi. Il y a aussi, comme je disais un peu tout à l'heure-
Ah oui, y a pas de piste, ouais.
...la sensibilité. Par exemple, j'ai vu une étude scientifique qui disait que, si tu prends une personne qui de base sourit et ensuite, tu fais cent photos jusqu'à ce que la personne soit en colère.
Donc ça fait cent photos d'un passage de quelqu'un qui sourit à une personne qui est en colère.
Ouais.
Eh ben la plupart des gens, ils vont se rendre compte de cette différence d'émotion à la septantième photo, donc à septante pour cent, alors que les gens qui ont le trouble borderline, ce sera uniquement à la trentième photo.
Donc on a vraiment une capacité à pouvoir analyser les émotions des autres. Moi, ça m'est déjà arrivé plein de fois de dire à mes amis : ''T'es sûr que tout va bien ?
J'ai l'impression que quelque chose ne va pas.'' La personne me partage en effet : ''Ah mais oui, t'as raison, Fio.'' En fait, ça n'allait pas et je m'en rendais même pas compte.
Donc, je m'en suis rendu compte avant elle parce que j'ai vu des choses différentes dans son visage, sa manière d'être.
Donc on a vraiment une capacité à pouvoir voir les choses et avec une empathie en fait qui est vraiment exacerbée quoi.
Et donc empathie plutôt au niveau des émotions, alors du ressenti, de est-ce que la personne est en colère, triste, voilà, ça oui.
C'est grosse déformation de ma part, mais quand... empathie cognitive, par exemple, au niveau de si une personne fait un sous-entendu ou qu'une personne fait une blague et que est-ce qu'elle a bien aimé la blague ?
Est-ce qu'elle a trouvé la blague nulle ? Est-ce qu'elle a pas compris la blague, etc. ? Là, à ce niveau-là, tu dirais que t'es dans la norme ? T'es...
Ben moi, personnellement, mais là, c'est vraiment très propre à moi. Souvent, je ne comprends pas les sous-entendus.
Ok.
Donc après, à voir si c'est pas trouble autistique, mais des fois, je ne comprends pas. Mais sinon, de manière globale, dépendant de la blague, en fait, on peut vraiment avoir tendance à prendre tout personnellement quoi.
Donc du coup, il y a vraiment le côté où au début, moi, je me rends compte, des fois, je manque d'empathie parce qu'en fait, je ne comprends pas la personne et/ou je vais avoir tendance à le prendre personnellement.
Mais si, et maintenant, je le fais et j'en parle avec la personne de façon non violente et que là, la personne m'explique pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a agi de la sorte.
Expliciter, ouais.
Voilà. Ben là, du coup, ça me rassure parce que du coup, je le prends plus personnellement. Et surtout, comme elle m'a expliqué clairement pourquoi elle agissait de cette manière, ben grâce à cela, donc j'ai beaucoup d'empathie
et je comprends les besoins de la personne et je les respecte.
Mais j'ai ce besoin que ce soit dit. Si c'est pas dit, moi, je ne comprends pas quoi.
Mais pour revenir à ce que tu disais à la base sur les recherches Google ou beaucoup, beaucoup de guides pour arriver à supporter la personne borderline dans sa vie, oui, je sens que ça... je comprends que ça te saoule intensément.
Mais malgré ça, j'ai quand même envie de poser une question à ce niveau-là. C'est-à-dire que je te disais que ça faisait écho à des expériences que j'avais pu avoir par le passé...
Attends, juste où la personne avait le trouble borderline ou en tout cas le style d'attachement désorganisé ? Elle était diagnostiquée ?
Non, pas diagnostiquée, mais en rétrospective, par exemple, sur tout ce que t'as dit par rapport à l'idéalisation, le fait de... une fois qu'on se parlait plus, elle me détestait, mais intensément.
Oui, des émotions très très très intenses pour des trucs très très cons.
Ouais.
Y a pas mal de choses où en rétrospective, je me dis : ''Ah ouais, quand même,
c'est quand même assez, assez, assez frappant.''
Mais du coup, voilà, comme tu l'as expliqué plusieurs fois, ça fait des relations pas forcément très faciles, surtout si la personne n'est pas diagnostiquée et qu'elle se gère pas plus que ça.
Du coup, qu'est-ce que tu conseillerais aux personnes qui sont pas borderline dans la relation, mais de l'autre côté, ouais ?
Du coup, très très bonne question, merci, parce qu'en effet, c'est un sujet qui est important d'aborder aussi. Et là, ben je pense que ça demande,
ben beaucoup de choses et c'est clair que vraiment, vraiment, je me doute que ça doit vraiment pas être évident.
Je me suis souvent mis à la place de mes ex et je me suis dit : ''Mais putain, ils en ont quand même bien bavé.'' Donc je comprends tout à fait.
Je pense que ça demande en fait de fixer des limites, en fait, de mettre un cadre et de fixer des limites et de se connaître en fait soi-même et de vraiment d'un côté être patient et bienveillant et de valider les émotions.
Ça, c'est super important. Donc surtout ne pas dire : ''Tu dramatises, tu exagères.'' Donc vraiment de valider les émotions en disant : ''Ah oui, je comprends.'' D'être un bon soutien émotionnel : ''Oui, je comprends.
Ça doit pas être évident. Je ne peux pas imaginer ce que tu ressens, mais en tout cas, je suis là, je suis avec toi.'' Et donc vraiment valider la personne, ça va permettre de beaucoup apaiser et en même temps de poser un cadre quoi.
Donc si la personne qui a un trouble borderline demande sans cesse : ''Est-ce que tu m'aimes ? Est-ce que tu m'aimes ? Est-ce que tu m'aimes
?'' cinquante fois par jour, c'est à un moment poser un cadre en disant : ''Tu as le droit de me poser la question cinq fois'' et c'est cinq fois quoi.
Par exemple, j'en sais rien, mais je donne un exemple, mais...
Ça fait très on parle à un enfant quand tu dis ça comme ça.
Ben...
À trois, tu vas au lit, d'accord ?
Y a ce besoin de ca-- 'fin moi, un de mes ex disait souvent que j'avais besoin de cadre.
Ouais, dans ces relations, c'est pas génial quoi.
Y a, ben y a ce besoin quand même...
Traiter son partenaire comme un enfant.
Non, pas comme un enfant, mais de vraiment poser un cadre et en même temps de faire évoluer ce cadre quoi.
Mais poser un cadre, c'est presque parental comme responsabilité quoi.
Ouais, mais s'il y a pas de cadre posé, moi, je me suis rendu compte que j'avais toujours tendance dans le passé à toujours aller voir les limites de la personne quoi.
Je vais chercher quand est-ce qu'il y a la limite ? Et si la personne pose pas de limites, ben alors là, des fois, je peux me sentir étouffée parce que c'est sans fin quoi.
Et donc j'aime bien l'idée que la personne me dise : ben ça, ce sont mes limites, Fio. Comme ça, tu sais, c'est là quoi.
Donc va pas plus loin que ça. Et au moins, je le sais et ça me rassure, c'est sécurisant et ça permet d'apporter une certaine structure.
Donc ça, voilà, le cadre, il est là et c'est comme ça. Et on peut discuter pour peut-être faire évoluer le cadre, mais ça se fait au fur et à mesure quoi.
Ouais.
C'est là quoi.
Ok. Donc ça, c'est ton principal conseil pour les personnes qui sont en relation amicale ou romantique avec une-
Ouais. Et puis de connaître évidemment le trouble aussi, de s'informer sur le trouble, de s'éduquer à ça, d'essayer de comprendre, de conscientiser que c'est un réel problème et pas juste,
quelqu'un qui a des émotions un petit peu fortes quoi, qu'il y a un réel, ben, handicap, hein, visible qui est vraiment présent.
Donc de pas minimiser une fois de plus les ressentis, d'écouter en fait les besoins de la personne et de l'inciter évidemment à aller en psychothérapie.
C'est pas toujours facilement accepté par son partenaire, ça hein ?
Non, c'est pour ça que je trouve que... je comprends que les gens... d'être en relation, on va dire, par exemple, amoureuse avec quelqu'un qui a le trouble borderline, ça doit être vraiment difficile,
vraiment, et l'ayant vé-- 'fin, je peux imaginer vraiment ce que j'ai fait endurer, 'fin ce qui a pu se passer dans mes ex-relations.
Et donc je pense qu'en effet, ça peut être vraiment difficile
et qu'en même temps, si la personne
décide, la personne concernée décide vraiment d'y mettre du sien pour aller dans l'introspection, pour aller vers un mieux-être, ben alors là, je pense que les personnes qui ont un trouble borderline peuvent être aussi exceptionnelles quoi.
On est des personnes qui pouvons être passionnées. 'Fin moi, je sais que par exemple, je suis vraiment hyper affectueuse quoi, je fais beaucoup beaucoup pour l'autre, je fais plein de surprises, je suis hyper à l'écoute.
'Fin, je suis très intense quoi, du coup aussi, donc j'amène plein de choses, je-
On a l'impression que tu te vends sur ton profil Tinder. Moi aussi, je suis sympa en vrai.
J'ai pas que des aspects négatifs quoi. 'Fin c'est ce que je veux dire quoi. Y a-
Oui, oui, j'ai compris.
...y a plein de choses positives aussi quoi. Et,
et je pense que c'est très appréciable pour l'autre que dans les moments où j'idéalise l'autre, ben à mon avis, il doit se sentir vachement sur un piédestal quoi, parce que je suis là en train de l'idéaliser et lui dire : ''Mais tu es incroyable.''
C'est très sain comme relation, ça.
C'est pour ça que là, c'est important de trouver le juste milieu quoi. Moi, je-
Est-ce que c'est possible ? Est-ce que c'est facile ? Est-ce que c'est souvent le cas pour les personnes qui ont un trouble borderline ?
Ben j'ai entendu-
D'arriver à trouver le juste milieu.
J'ai entendu des témoignages de personnes, en tout cas, qui disaient qu'elles étaient en couple et heureuses.
Que c'était pas facile dans la vie de tous les jours, en même temps, quel couple est facile dans la vie de tous les jours ?
Et surtout que, moi, j'aime bien, du coup, alors là, à ce moment-là, c'est comparer ça avec l'alcool, dans le sens où en fait, le couple,
'fin pour ma part, en tout cas, comment je le vis, c'est qu'il y a une tendance quand même à vouloir fusionner parce qu'en fait, j'ai jamais trouvé autre chose que la passion d'aussi fort.
Donc y a vraiment cette envie de fusionner parce que c'est tellement fort, c'est tellement bon, c'est tellement intense.
Ouais, mais elle disparaît après cette envie de fusion-
Mais elle disparaît et du coup, évidemment, et du coup, l'idée, au même titre que l'alcool, donc là, j'ai fait le choix, par exemple, d'arrêter pendant un an,
mais je pense que l'idée, en fait, c'est de trouver vraiment ce juste milieu, donc de boire un verre de temps en temps, comme de passer un moment de temps en temps avec l'autre, 'fin régulièrement, bien sûr, mais aussi d'avoir ses trucs à soi-
Ouais, c'est ça.
...ses amis. Et même si c'est moins fort avec les amis, quand je les vois, c'est peut-être pas aussi intense en termes d'émotions, mais de quand même chérir ces moments-là, de quand même chérir les moments seuls.
Donc là, tu fais plutôt des conseils pour les personnes directement concernées qui doivent apprendre à peut-être un peu mieux se réguler, etc.
Oui.
Mais donc, si on imagine une personne, parce que j'en ai connu hein autour de moi, des gens qui étaient en situation de couple très très compliquée, avec des mots très forts et des engueulades hyper violentes. Et on... 'fin,
intuitivement, spontanément, on aurait envie de se dire : ''Il devrait peut-être un peu travailler sur ses émotions, un petit peu mieux se réguler, etc.''
Ce que tu décrivais, c'était finalement une personne qui a un trouble borderline et qui,
a appris à mieux se gérer, à mieux gérer ses émotions et aussi un partenaire ou une partenaire qui, voilà, sait être là pour son partenaire quand,
quand c'est nécessaire et qui, voilà, qui sait gérer le truc, qui est à la hauteur des enjeux.
Je pense-
Donc c'est-
Pardon.
C'est, mais c'est beaucoup, 'fin, c'est pas facile à trouver, 'fin tu, c'est beaucoup de conditions plus compliquées.
Donc dans les situations où on n'arrive pas à cette situation relativement idéale, voilà, tu disais, conseiller d'aller en psychothérapie, c'est pas toujours facilement accepté.
Est-ce que tu conseillerais à une personne qui est en relation avec une personne qui a un trouble borderline, et où on n'arrive pas à se diriger vers tout ça, vers ce scénario très,
très mûr et très encadré et très suivi psychologiquement et avec un travail sur les émotions.
Est-ce que tu leur conseillerais de juste se dire : ''Bon ben, ça va pas marcher quoi.''
Alors déjà, je conseillerais jamais ça parce que je trouve ça horrible. Je suis pas à la place... 'fin chaque relation est différente.
Bien sûr, chaque relation est différente.
Mais-
Mais, mais on a-
Je vois ce que tu veux dire.
Y a ce truc de culpabilité, de se dire : ''Mais non, je veux pas la faire culpabiliser pour qui elle est.
Je vais me battre un petit peu pour quand même faire marcher le truc et tout ça.'' Mais y a un peu un côté nager à contre-courant quoi.
Je pense qu'il y a une question,
donc en effet, pour reprendre juste ce que tu disais, en effet, c'est ça, c'est hyper important, idéalement,
que le conjoint ou la conjointe de la personne concernée ait une très grande maturité émotionnelle et que cette personne-là soit capable en fait
d'exprimer clairement ses émotions.
Je sais que moi, ce qui m'a beaucoup insécurisée dans mes anciennes relations, c'était de ne pas comprendre la psyché de l'autre.
Et plus la personne était honnête et authentique envers moi et me partageait ses émotions, plus-
Expliciter les choses, ouais.
...expliciter, voilà, plus je me sentais en sécurité. Mais en effet, du coup, quand c'est pas possible, 'fin comme tu dis, c'est un peu peut-être le monde des bisounours, mais c'est possible quand même hein.
C'est beaucoup de conditions à rassembler quoi.
Beaucoup de conditions, ouais. Et je pense que sinon, ben, moi, je pense, 'fin, je suis quand même une éternelle optimiste dans la vie, je pense que tout est possible.
Je pense que, ouais, que beaucoup de choses sont, en tout cas, sont vraiment possibles, mais que tout dépend en fait des limites de chacun et de chacune quoi.
Donc ça veut dire que c'est vraiment en permanence demander : ok là où j'en suis en tant que conjoint, conjointe de personnes concernées hein du coup.
Ok là où j'en suis avec moi-même, qu'est-ce que je suis capable d'accepter ou pas, et de poser ces limites en fait.
Et si les limites sont dépassées, ben de toujours en fait revenir à soi et de se dire à chaque fois quoi : moi en tant que conjoint, conjointe d'une personne où j'ai l'impression que par exemple la personne est concernée par un trouble borderline,
mais elle ne veut rien entendre ou je n'arrive pas à lui en parler ou quoi que ce soit,
je me demande comment je me sens dans cette relation et je reprends ce cadran un peu émotionnel à chaque fois de me dire, ben, où j'en suis et qu'est-ce que je suis capable d'accepter ou non.
En permanence quoi. Et y a rien de figé hein évidemment, et ça, c'est hyper important, y a rien de figé.
Et y a que soi-même en fait qui peut répondre à cette question quoi. À quel moment est-ce que je pars d'une relation ou pas quoi ?
Très bien. Mais Fiona, c'était super intéressant. On t'a diagnostiqué plusieurs troubles. Mais non, c'était super intéressant.
Ben du coup, j'ai vraiment appris des choses vis-à-vis de notamment, 'fin plein de choses, mais le truc du est-ce qu'on a ou est-ce qu'on
naît, je trouvais ça super intéressant parce que j'avais pas vu les choses sous cet angle-là.
Cool.
Et je suis certain qu'il y a plein de personnes qui nous écoutent et qui ont appris plein de choses au sujet de peut-être des gens dans leur entourage et qui arrivent à comprendre des choses en rétrospective.
On l'a dit, encore beaucoup de lacunes au niveau des professionnels de santé, au niveau de la formation. Toi, finalement, ce que tu proposes avec ton compte Instagram et ton site et ton livre, c'est
un circuit parallèle pour s'informer soi-même et prendre son initiative vis-à-vis de ces questions-là.
Ben c'est plein de choses différentes. Ça va être, déjà, du soutien émotionnel, le fait de se sentir-
Communauté, ouais.
...voilà, communauté, on se sent moins seul, on se sent compris, comprise, inclus, incluse. Donc ça, c'est tout le côté émotionnel.
Il va y avoir la vulgarisation de contenu aussi, où j'explique de façon un peu plus neurophysiologique les choses parce que, même si je suis pas professionnelle de la santé, j'adore ça.
Y a beaucoup de contenu gratuit sur mon site, donc un workbook par exemple, avec des habitudes pour prendre soin de soi, des témoignages aussi de... j'ai,
c'est un e-book que j'ai créé gratuitement avec septante témoignages de personnes concernées par le trouble qui m'avaient envoyé ça.
Donc voilà, donc ça va être du soutien, de la vulgarisation de contenu, des habitudes, des outils concrets pour aller vers un mieux-être.
Et ça va être aussi, ben beaucoup d'espoir en fait. Étant une personne concernée, c'est vraiment cette envie de dire : c'est pas tous les jours facile, mais y a moyen d'aller de mieux en mieux quoi.
Super. Merci beaucoup.
Merci beaucoup.
À très bientôt pour un prochain épisode. Un grand merci à Fiona, c'était passionnant. J'ai appris beaucoup de choses grâce à son histoire.
Merci à elle d'avoir partagé son vécu publiquement comme ça et franchement, grand respect pour le combat qu'elle a dû mener et tout ce qu'elle a réussi à accomplir, c'est très inspirant.
Du coup, on lui pardonne son nez bouché et son chat qui miaule en arrière-plan. Je pense que vous avez dû l'entendre.
On se retrouve très bientôt pour deux épisodes avant la fin de saison. Et puis plein de bonnes surprises à la rentrée. Ciao, ciao, ciao.